You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an
你知道，你的眼睛承受了很多。每天阅读、在昏暗的灯光下工作、长时间盯着屏幕——这种情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光，甚至夜间驾驶都会导致眼睛疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛负担很重。因此，定期进行眼科检查以呵护并监测眼睛健康非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行眼科检查，价格仅需 99 美元起，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段发现眼部和健康状况。要查找您附近的门店并预约眼科检查，请访问...
OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.cavers.ca. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. We've all been there, the unexpected hosting panic. Like when the watch party finally makes it out of the group chat, but you volunteered to host. And suddenly you need snacks, drinks, dips, cups, and all the other party essentials, no one else planned for. With Instacart, you can get all those groceries delivered in as fast as 60 minutes. No extra errands for you. One quick order for everyone. That way, everything shows up right on time, making hosting easy and making it look like you had it planned all along. Download the Instacart app today and get no markups at select retailers. Fees and in-store offer exclusions apply.
OCT 扫描 99 美元起，请访问 specsavers.ca。眼科检查由独立验光师提供。价格可能因地点而异。我们都有过这样的经历，突如其来的招待恐慌。比如当观看派对终于从群聊中落实，而你却自告奋勇担任东道主。突然间，你需要零食、饮料、蘸酱、杯子以及所有其他人没想到的派对必需品。通过 Instacart，你可以在 60 分钟内送达所有这些杂货。无需额外跑腿。为每个人快速下单。这样，一切都能准时送达，让招待变得轻松，看起来就像你一直都在计划一样。立即下载 Instacart 应用程序，在指定零售商处享受无加价优惠。适用费用和店内优惠排除条款。
Welcome to your second drink of Night Out. This is a good one. We have audio clips from Noel who played Troy and Kate. Yes. And I'm going to kick things off with a fan letter from Sarah B in New York. It's about the cold open where Michael gets gum in his hair and Dwight is putting peanut butter in it, you know, to get it out. Sarah said, there's a line in the cold open where Dwight says, tastes good too. Oh, that's a lot of calories. And Michael says, well, just don't leave it on for too long. Sarah said it's one of my favorite lines of the whole show. It's so smartly done and so under the breath of both characters that it passed by me the first few times I watched the episode. It's an absolute genius line. I have to know was the scripted or improvised, maybe a little bit of both.
欢迎来到《Night Out》的第二杯饮品。这一集很棒。我们有 Noel 的音频片段，他在剧中饰演 Troy 和 Kate。是的。我要先从纽约 Sarah B 的一封粉丝来信开始。是关于那个冷开场，Michael 的头发里粘了口香糖，Dwight 正在往里面抹花生酱，你知道的，为了把它弄出来。Sarah 说，冷开场里有一句台词，Dwight 说：“味道也不错。”哦，那热量很高。然后 Michael 说：“好吧，只是别留太久。”Sarah 说这是她整部剧中最喜欢的台词之一。它做得太聪明了，而且两个角色的语气都那么轻描淡写，以至于我前几次看这一集时都没注意到。这绝对是天才般的台词。我必须知道这是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的，也许两者都有。
The delivery is just as good as the line itself. Well, and Sarah is not the only person who wrote in about this moment. This is really a fan favorite moment. So I checked the shooting draft and this is 100% scripted. Word for word. Amazing. That's great writing but also such great delivery. that people thought it was off the cuff. Well, one of the things we both loved about this episode was Michael's slow clap. And I got curious about the origins of the slow clap. And I thought I had found the origin of the slow clap in cinema. Yes.
演绎得和台词本身一样好。嗯，Sarah 并不是唯一写信提到这个时刻的人。这确实是粉丝最喜欢的时刻。所以我查了拍摄剧本，这 100% 是剧本写的。逐字逐句。太棒了。那是很棒的写作，但演绎得也太好了，以至于人们以为是即兴发挥的。嗯，我们俩都喜欢这一集的一点是 Michael 的慢速鼓掌。我对慢速鼓掌的起源感到好奇。我以为我找到了电影中慢速鼓掌的起源。是的。
But we got this letter from Jonathan J. That might prove otherwise. Jonathan says, not so much a question, but a catch. The internet was wrong. You put that in all caps. The first slow clap is not in the lion in winter from 1968. It is Julie Andrews and Mary Poppins in 1964. Right before Jolly Holiday, she slow claps Bert's trapeze performance that he does for none other than the character of Michael.
但我们收到了 Jonathan J 的这封信。这可能证明并非如此。Jonathan 说，与其说是问题，不如说是一个发现。互联网错了。你把那几个字全大写了。第一次慢速鼓掌不是在 1968 年的《冬狮》里。而是在 1964 年朱莉·安德鲁斯主演的《欢乐满人间》里。就在《Jolly Holiday》之前，她对 Bert 的空中飞人表演进行了慢速鼓掌，而他表演的对象正是 Michael 这个角色。
Jonathan goes on to say there may be others that came before, but as far as I'm concerned, Mary Poppins invented the slow clap and won Julie Andrews and Oscar for doing so. Well, we both went and watched this clip. Yeah, we need to discuss. I have thoughts. I do too. Should we play it? Sure. World famous artis perform a defiant feats of dexterity and skill before your burial.
Jonathan 继续说，可能还有更早的，但就我而言，《欢乐满人间》发明了慢速鼓掌，并让朱莉·安德鲁斯因此赢得了奥斯卡奖。好吧，我们俩都去看了这个片段。是的，我们需要讨论一下。我有想法。我也有。我们要播放它吗？当然。世界著名的艺术家在你们埋葬之前表演了大胆的灵巧和技巧。
Okay. It is or it isn't. Okay. One, two, three. No. You didn't say it isn't, by the way. You didn't even follow the rules we just said. It's not.
好吧。是还是不是。好吧。一，二，三。不。顺便说一句，你没说不是。你甚至没遵守我们刚才说的规则。不是。
I think it's a slow clap. It has the sass and it's slow. She's sassing him. It's sarcastic, but I think of the slow clap as the slow clap that then gets bigger and now we're clapping. No, you've missed the whole point of the slow clap, lady. What? Slow clap is snark. It's nothing happy about it.
我觉得那是慢速鼓掌。它有那种傲慢，而且很慢。她在对他傲慢。那是讽刺性的，但我认为慢速鼓掌是那种先慢后快，然后大家一起鼓掌的。不，你完全没理解慢速鼓掌的重点，女士。什么？慢速鼓掌是嘲讽。它一点也不快乐。
No. Honey, slow clap is like you've just done something. Sam. Oh, my God. Jenna, you don't speed up on. a slow clap. Yes, you do speed up on a slow clap. You don't. Maybe if you're happy for the person, uh, can't buy me love. Slow clap into a big clap. Yeah, the slow clap, it does go faster. These are two types of claps, though, because there's the slow clap that amps up,
不。亲爱的，慢速鼓掌就像是你刚刚做成了某事。Sam。天哪。Jenna，你不会在慢速鼓掌时加速。是的，你在慢速鼓掌时会加速。你不会。也许如果你为那个人感到高兴的话，呃，《不能买我爱》。慢速鼓掌变成大鼓掌。是的，慢速鼓掌确实会变快。不过这是两种鼓掌，因为有一种是会增强的慢速鼓掌，
but then there's the smart ass clap and that never amps up. You guys are talking about two separate claps. Yes, we are. Yeah, so which is the one that Michael does in the episode? Isn't it this one that gets then faster. I don't remember. I have to go, wait, I can't comment because I don't remember. It makes me guys. Oh, it says, Michael starts a sarcastic slow clap for Ryan after Kelly demands answers about the website's problems. But I love it if you could find it.
但还有一种是自作聪明的鼓掌，那种永远不会增强。你们在谈论两种不同的鼓掌。是的，我们是。是的，那么 Michael 在那一集中做的是哪一种？不是那种后来变快的吗？我不记得了。我得去，等等，我不能评论，因为我不记得了。这让我……天哪。哦，上面写着，Michael 在 Kelly 要求对网站问题做出解释后，开始为 Ryan 进行讽刺性的慢速鼓掌。但我很想如果你能找到它。
Do you have a question, Kelly? Yeah, I have a lot of questions. Number one, how dare you? Ryan is on a very good job, and I am not applauding sarcastically. You are looking at me right now with slow clapping eyes. Mm-hmm. Because I was not talking about the slow clap that leads to the big clap. I was talking about smart-ass slow clap.
你有问题吗，Kelly？是的，我有很多问题。第一，你怎么敢？Ryan 正在做一份非常好的工作，我不是在讽刺地鼓掌。你现在正用慢速鼓掌的眼神看着我。嗯哼。因为我说的不是那种导致大鼓掌的慢速鼓掌。我说的是自作聪明的慢速鼓掌。
All right. I stand corrected. And I do think Julie Andrews did that. Well, then, yes, Julie Andrews was sarcastically slow clapping. Mm-hmm. So good catch, Jonathan. But a slow clap can lead to a fast clap. No one is disputing that.
好吧。我收回我的话。而且我确实认为朱莉·安德鲁斯那样做了。好吧，那么，是的，朱莉·安德鲁斯是在讽刺地慢速鼓掌。嗯哼。所以，好发现，Jonathan。但慢速鼓掌确实可以导致快速鼓掌。没人反驳这一点。
It's just not what happened in this episode. Well, finally, at the end of this episode, you know, everyone's trapped in the parking lot, and we discussed a few what I might now call bullshit cards. I like it. Like, why did Hank lock the gate when there were so many cars still there? But we got this letter from Sarah C that I'd like to throw into the Vicks. Got it, go. Sarah C said, when they were all trapped in the building,
只是这一集里发生的情况并非如此。好吧，最后，在这一集的结尾，你知道，每个人都被困在停车场里，我们讨论了一些我现在可能称之为“胡扯”的情节。我喜欢这个说法。比如，为什么 Hank 在还有那么多车的时候锁上了大门？但我们收到了 Sarah C 的这封信，我想把它扔进讨论池里。明白了，说吧。Sarah C 说，当他们都被困在楼里时，
why didn't Phyllis call Bob Vance of Vance refrigeration to get them out? Wouldn't he have a key for the gate? Hell yes, Sarah, he would have. He really would have. None of us thought of it. Well, you guys, that is all we have. And now it's time for your second drink of Night Out.
为什么 Phyllis 不给 Vance 制冷的 Bob Vance 打电话让他们出来？他难道没有大门的钥匙吗？该死，是的，Sarah，他会有。他真的会有。我们谁都没想过。好吧，伙计们，这就是我们所有的内容了。现在是时候喝你的第二杯《Night Out》了。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories
我是 Jenna Fisher。我是 Angela Kinsey。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供独家的幕后故事，
that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello, everybody. Hi, you guys. We have a very exciting episode today. It is Season 4, Episode 15, Night Out. Yeah, we traveled, we went on the road, there was locations and tons of extras.
只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嗨，伙计们。我们今天有一集非常令人兴奋的内容。这是第四季第 15 集，《Night Out》。是的，我们旅行了，我们上路了，有外景和大量的临时演员。
This was a big production for us. Very little happens in the office. That's right. Well, this was written by Mindy Kaling, directed by Ken Whittingham, And today, we have a surprise. I'm not reading the summary again today. Jenna's going to skip out on her duties.
这对我们来说是一次大制作。办公室里发生的事情很少。没错。好吧，这一集是由 Mindy Kaling 编写的，Ken Whittingham 执导，今天，我们有一个惊喜。我今天不会再读摘要了。Jenna 要逃避她的职责了。
Sorry. Geez, I mean, I know. Was I throwing you shade a little bit? Skip out. Well, we have a super fan who wanted to read the summary. For today's episode, it's Terry Carnation. Terry, welcome. Thank you so much for having me.
抱歉。天哪，我是说，我知道。我是在稍微给你脸色看吗？逃避。好吧，我们有一位超级粉丝想读摘要。今天的这一集，是 Terry Carnation。Terry，欢迎。非常感谢你们邀请我。
I am a huge fan, as you previously stated, of Office Women podcast, and you, Jennifer Fisher and Angel, everything that you guys do and this show, which is just so hysterically funny. This episode, in particular, I'm so thrilled to be summarizing for your listening pleasure. Well, we're happy to have you, Terry. Yes. Thank you. Angela, not Angel, but I appreciate. Of course, Angela, but you are an angel.
正如你们之前所说，我是《办公室》女性播客的超级粉丝，还有你们，Jennifer Fisher 和 Angel，你们所做的一切以及这个节目，真是太搞笑了。这一集，特别地，我非常激动能为你们的听众进行总结。好吧，我们很高兴有你，Terry。是的。谢谢。Angela，不是 Angel，但我很感激。当然是 Angela，但你是个天使。
After all, let's not forget. Oh, excellent. Well, should I jump right in? Office women? Please, let's do it. Excellent. This episode is entitled The Night Away, and it is an excellent episode that features James Halpert and his wife, Pamela, and they are striving to consummate their relationship. And apparently there's a young fellow named Dwight Scruti and his, his,
毕竟，别忘了。哦，太棒了。好吧，我应该直接开始吗？《办公室》女性？请吧，让我们开始吧。太棒了。这一集名为《The Night Away》，这是一集非常出色的剧集，讲述了 James Halpert 和他的妻子 Pamela，他们正在努力圆满他们的关系。显然有一个叫 Dwight Scruti 的年轻人，还有他的，他的，
his best friend, Scott Michael, they are running across New York City in this episode. It seems that Ryan has gotten into a little trouble with the devil's candy. And by that I mean that fierce little lady, cocaine. Terry, I have a question. Have you seen this episode? I haven't seen this episode in particular. I have seen an episode of this show. And this is my theory, if I may share it with you, too.
他的好朋友 Scott Michael，他们在这一集中跑遍了纽约市。看起来 Ryan 在“魔鬼的糖果”上遇到了一点麻烦。我指的是那个凶猛的小女士，可卡因。Terry，我有个问题。你看过这一集吗？我没看过这一集。我看过这个节目的一集。这是我的理论，如果我可以和你们分享的话。
About The Office? The building is possessed. Why else would the people inside it act the way they do? Why would this delightful Pamela fall in love with that floppy-haired misfit, James Halpert? It makes no sense. People behaving in just absurd ways. The building is possessed. The building itself may be a demon.
关于《办公室》？这栋楼被附身了。否则里面的人为什么要那样行事？为什么这个可爱的 Pamela 会爱上那个头发软塌塌的怪胎 James Halpert？这毫无意义。人们的行为方式简直荒谬。这栋楼被附身了。这栋楼本身可能是一个恶魔。
And Dwight Scruti himself may be some kind of dibic or homunculus. You think there's paranormal activity. In fact, several members of the office might be from hell. I am here merely to speculate. I am saying that perhaps there is a story underneath the story. Yes, this is a light comedy about coworkers, hardy-har-har. But underneath it all, there may be something far more nefarious. Wow.
而 Dwight Scruti 本人可能是什么样的恶灵或人造人。你认为有超自然活动。事实上，办公室里的几个人可能来自地狱。我在这里只是为了推测。我是说也许故事下面还有一个故事。是的，这是一部关于同事的轻喜剧，哈哈大笑。但在这一切之下，可能有一些更邪恶的东西。哇。
Terry, how many episodes have you seen? Just the one? I am planning on starting to watch this show as soon as we finish this podcast, because it is bewitching me. It has bewitched me. Okay. So you haven't seen any episodes then? I have not. And have you listened to any episodes of Dark Air with Terry Carnation? No, you have not. So we're even Stephen. Okay. Well, I don't think we've...
Terry，你看过多少集？就那一集？我打算在我们完成这个播客后就开始看这个节目，因为它让我着迷。它让我着迷。好吧。所以你还没看过任何一集？我没有。你听过《Dark Air with Terry Carnation》的任何一集吗？不，你没有。所以我们扯平了。好吧。嗯，我不认为我们……
That show, Even Stevens, I have watched every episode of Even Stevens. Okay. Well, Terry, I think there might have been a miscommunication with your agent. Big fan. Huge fan. Thank you so much for having me. Office Women and all of the listeners. Thank you for enjoying this show and these two delightful young women as they share their inner torment with you on a weekly basis. Thank you, Terry Carnation, and I'm sure everyone will want to check out Dark Air. It's going to premiere April 1st on Audio Boom. Terry, we'd love to have you back if you ever start watching the show. If you watch an episode, let us know.
那个节目，《Even Stevens》，我看过每一集。好吧。嗯，Terry，我觉得你的经纪人可能沟通有误。大粉丝。超级粉丝。非常感谢你们邀请我。《办公室》女性和所有的听众。感谢你们喜欢这个节目，以及这两位可爱的年轻女性，因为她们每周都在与你们分享她们内心的折磨。谢谢你，Terry Carnation，我相信每个人都会想去看看《Dark Air》。它将于 4 月 1 日在 Audio Boom 首播。Terry，如果你开始看这个节目，我们很乐意让你回来。如果你看了一集，告诉我们。
I really should do that. It looks fascinating. Well, thank you, Terry. There is one young accountant blonde woman who I find very intriguing. Oh, boy. Really? Fictionally speaking, thank you for having me, office women. Thank you, Terry. Goodbye, Terry.
我真的应该那样做。看起来很迷人。好吧，谢谢你，Terry。有一位年轻的会计金发女士，我觉得非常有趣。哦，天哪。真的吗？从虚构的角度来说，谢谢你们邀请我，《办公室》女性。谢谢你，Terry。再见，Terry。
Goodbye. Lady, he'd never seen the show. I don't. He had no idea what we were talking about. He also sounded suspiciously like Rain Wilson. He really did. He really did. He called me Angel.
再见。女士们，他从来没看过这个节目。我不知道。他根本不知道我们在说什么。他听起来也极其像 Rain Wilson。他真的太像了。他真的太像了。他叫我 Angel。
Well, that was an adventure. We tried something. That was exciting and confusing. I feel like we have some phone calls to make after we're done. Yeah, I feel like we're going to text some people. All right, should we get into this episode? Should you actually read a summary? I'd be happy to.
好吧，那真是一次冒险。我们尝试了一些事情。那既令人兴奋又令人困惑。我觉得我们做完后得打几个电话。是的，我觉得我们要给一些人发短信。好吧，我们应该进入这一集吗？你应该真的读一下摘要吗？我很乐意。
A lonely Michael and Dwight go to New York City to party with Ryan and meet ladies. In the meantime, the Scranton employees work late to avoid working over the weekend, but they wind up getting locked into the Scranton business park. And Terry did get this part right. Ryan may have a drug problem. Oh, man. Yeah. What are your fast facts?
孤独的 Michael 和 Dwight 去纽约市与 Ryan 聚会并结识女士。与此同时，Scranton 的员工加班以避免周末工作，但他们最终被锁在了 Scranton 商业园区。Terry 确实说对了这一部分。Ryan 可能有毒品问题。哦，天哪。是的。你的快速事实是什么？
Here's a fast fact for you, Ang. I thought we could do a little breakdown of our guest star Troy Underbridge. This is his second appearance on the show. You guys know he first showed up in the deposition. He is played by Noel Ptock and we reached out to him. Yes, we did. And Noel was so sweet. He sent in a bunch of audio clips, and he had some fun stories to share with us.
给你一个快速事实，Ang。我想我们可以对我们的客串明星 Troy Underbridge 进行一点剖析。这是他第二次出现在节目中。你们知道他第一次出现在《Deposition》中。他由 Noel Ptock 饰演，我们联系了他。是的，我们联系了。Noel 太贴心了。他发来了一堆音频片段，他有一些有趣的经历要和我们分享。
Well, the first thing we wanted to know, we asked a lot of our guests, how did he get the job on the office? And here's what he had to say. Hello, office ladies. This is Noel P. Top. And I don't recall, really, Allison Jones ever having the audition. I actually started the whole process doing background through central casting. So I did, I think just one episode where I did background. I was not really goofing off, but acted like I was kind of goofing off, texting on a phone.
嗯，我们想知道的第一件事，我们问了很多嘉宾，他是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？这是他要说的。你好，《办公室》女士们。我是 Noel P. Top。我不记得 Allison Jones 让我试镜过。我实际上是通过 Central Casting 做背景演员开始整个过程的。所以我记得只有一集我做了背景演员。我并没有真的在胡闹，但表现得好像我在胡闹，在手机上发短信。
I was kind of the posse of Ryan, E.J. Novak's character and had a good time doing it. I mean, just enjoyed the process. And later down the line, I had gotten a phone call from the assistant director. and she said she had spoken to Allison Jones and asked me if I'd like to appear on a couple episodes here and there. But I didn't actually auditioned. They just kind of offered me the role and I gladly accepted. So Angela, when I was a struggling actor, I did tons of background work in the hopes that someone would sort of discover me and give me a speaking role. It never happened.
我算是 Ryan，也就是 B.J. Novak 角色的随从，玩得很开心。我是说，只是享受这个过程。后来，我接到了助理导演的电话，她说她和 Allison Jones 谈过了，问我是否愿意在这里和那里出现在几集里。但我并没有真正试镜。他们只是给了我这个角色，我很高兴地接受了。所以 Angela，当我是一个挣扎的演员时，我做了大量的背景工作，希望有人能发现我并给我一个有台词的角色。这从未发生过。
It's super rare. but it did happen on our show. I mean, that's literally how Creed ended up becoming a series regular on our show. He started doing background work. And it's just something that I kind of like about our show. Yeah, me too. And this was also true for some of our warehouse employees that really just started as background characters.
这超级罕见。但它确实在我们的节目中发生了。我是说，这简直就是 Creed 最终成为我们节目常规角色的方式。他开始做背景工作。这正是我们节目中我喜欢的一种东西。是的，我也是。对于我们的一些仓库员工来说也是如此，他们确实只是从背景角色开始。
And then as years went by, they got to have speaking parts. And as an actor, that is so thrilling. But I love that Noel was there and that they went on to use him in several episodes. Well, that was due in large part to Mindy Kaling, and he actually talks about that in this next audio clip. You know, Mindy wrote this episode. So here's what he had to say. There is most definitely one person I'd like to thank who actually, I believe, wrote my character originally, and that is Mindy who came up with the character, and she kind of came through in the office and ended up getting her own show.
然后随着岁月的流逝，他们开始有了台词。作为一名演员，这太令人激动了。但我喜欢 Noel 在那里，而且他们后来在几集中使用了他。嗯，这在很大程度上要归功于 Mindy Kaling，他实际上在下一个音频片段中谈到了这一点。你知道，Mindy 写了这一集。所以这是他要说的。绝对有一个人我想感谢，实际上，我相信，最初写了我的角色，那就是 Mindy，她想出了这个角色，她以某种方式进入了办公室，并最终有了自己的节目。
and Mindy is incredible. She's so sweet and smart. And I've got to thank Mindy for writing up this character, which was a blast to play. So sweet. I love that. Me too. Well, we have even more audio clips from Noel that we're going to share later in the show. And he is just the nicest guy.
Mindy 太不可思议了。她太贴心又聪明了。我得感谢 Mindy 写了这个角色，演起来真是太棒了。太贴心了。我喜欢这个。我也是。嗯，我们还有更多 Noel 的音频片段，我们稍后会在节目中分享。他真是个最好的人。
It was so nice to get to reconnect with him. Yeah. All right. My lady, what is your next fast fact? My next fast fact is a location. break down because we got some fan questions. From Abby, Lana and Natalie, who would like to know was this episode filmed in an actual nightclub? And Mariah Kaye asked, are they different clubs?
能和他重新联系真是太好了。是的。好吧。我的女士，你的下一个快速事实是什么？我的下一个快速事实是一个地点剖析，因为我们收到了一些粉丝的问题。来自 Abby、Lana 和 Natalie，她们想知道这一集是在真正的夜总会拍摄的吗？Mariah Kaye 问，它们是不同的俱乐部吗？
You know, the guys go to two different clubs? Yeah, yeah. Did we film in different locations? Or is it just two rooms in the same building? Well, I'll tell you guys. Tell us. In the episode, Michael and Dwight and Ryan and Troy, they go party at clubs. in New York City, these club scenes were all filmed in downtown Los Angeles at the Edison
你知道，男人们去了两个不同的俱乐部？是的，是的。我们在不同的地点拍摄了吗？还是只是同一栋楼里的两个房间？嗯，我会告诉你们。告诉我们。在这一集中，Michael 和 Dwight 以及 Ryan 和 Troy，他们去纽约市的俱乐部聚会，这些俱乐部场景都是在洛杉矶市中心的 Edison
Nightclub. Now, the Edison Night Club is really big, and they had several different rooms, and they dressed them to look like two different clubs. So we only went to one location, and we knocked it all out, and they filled the club with all background actors. But, Ang, the Edison actually has a very cool history. The nightclub? Yes, have you ever been there? Not only have I never been there. I've never heard of it, and I've lived in L.A. for over 20 years now. And if that tells you my hip factor, I had never heard of this nightclub.
夜总会拍摄的。现在，Edison 夜总会真的很大，他们有几个不同的房间，他们把它们装饰成看起来像两个不同的俱乐部。所以我们只去了一个地点，我们把它全部搞定了，他们用所有的背景演员填满了俱乐部。但是，Ang，Edison 实际上有一段非常酷的历史。那个夜总会？是的，你去过那里吗？我不仅没去过那里。我甚至没听说过它，而且我在洛杉矶已经住了 20 多年了。如果这能说明我的时髦程度，我从来没听说过这个夜总会。
Me either. Angela, the only nightclub I've ever been to and have still ever been to is the one you took me to for my Bachelorette party. That's it. That's so crazy. And I had never heard of that one. Remember, that was like a friend of a friend
我也没听说过。Angela，我唯一去过而且至今仍然去过的夜总会就是你带我去参加单身派对的那一个。就是那样。太疯狂了。我从来没听说过那一个。记得吗，那就像是一个朋友的朋友，
who was like trying to help me plan a night out for you. Okay, go on. Well, the Edison Nightclub is in a historic building. It's called the Higgins building. And it was the site of L.A.'s first private power plant. How about that? In downtown L.A.? Yeah.
试图帮我为你计划一个夜晚。好吧，继续。嗯，Edison 夜总会位于一栋历史建筑中。它叫 Higgins 大楼。它是洛杉矶第一个私人发电厂的所在地。怎么样？在洛杉矶市中心？是的。
Wow. But here's the most interesting part, at least to me. They have a dress code because, quote, we are dedicated to a resurgence of old world style and a sense of romance that once dominated Los Angeles nightlife. So the nightclub, you have to look like fancy, like you got to wear suits and dresses and whatnot? Well, I think that's what they're hoping for. Basically, after 9 p.m., there are certain things you cannot wear. So here's the list of things you cannot wear. Why do I feel like this is going to rule me out? Oh, yeah, because listen to the first thing you can't wear. Athletic wear. Oh, no. All my a leisure wear. This includes shorts, jerseys, hoodies, and baseball caps. So Josh can't go. I can't go. You also can't have a backpack. Oh. You cannot. You cannot. wear flip-flops, sandals, short-sleeve shirts, or excessively torn or baggy jeans. Short-sleeved shirts, that's interesting. I mean, it gets hot here. Sorry. Don't know what to tell you.
哇。但这是最有趣的部分，至少对我来说。他们有着装要求，因为，“我们致力于复兴旧世界的风格和曾经主导洛杉矶夜生活的浪漫感。”所以夜总会，你必须看起来很时髦，比如你必须穿西装和裙子之类的？嗯，我想这就是他们所希望的。基本上，晚上 9 点以后，有些东西你不能穿。所以这是你不能穿的东西清单。为什么我觉得这会把我排除在外？哦，是的，因为听听你不能穿的第一件事。运动装。哦，不。我所有的休闲装。这包括短裤、球衣、连帽衫和棒球帽。所以 Josh 不能去。我不能去。你也不能背背包。哦。你不能。你不能。穿人字拖、凉鞋、短袖衬衫或过度破损或宽松的牛仔裤。短袖衬衫，这很有趣。我是说，这里很热。抱歉。不知道该告诉你什么。
But if you would like to go to the location where we film night out, you can go, but dress spiffy. There you have it, folks. And lady, that's all I got. I know I normally do three fast facts, but Terry ate up a lot of our time, and I think we should just go to a break and come back and get into this episode. Are you using Terry to cover up the fact that you don't have three fast facts? We'll see you after this break. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Sometimes it can feel like everyone else has it all together. Their love life, even whether they're married or dating or single, like they've got it figured out. But the truth is I think we're all still figuring it out. No matter where you are in your romantic journey, therapy is kind of great because you have someone to talk it out with,
但如果你想去我们拍摄《Night Out》的地点，你可以去，但要穿得时髦点。伙计们，这就是全部了。女士，这就是我所有的内容。我知道我通常做三个快速事实，但 Terry 占用了我们很多时间，我觉得我们应该休息一下，回来后再进入这一集。你是在用 Terry 来掩盖你没有三个快速事实的事实吗？休息后见。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。有时感觉好像其他人都把一切都搞定了。他们的爱情生活，无论是结婚、约会还是单身，就像他们已经弄清楚了一样。但事实是，我认为我们都在摸索。无论你在浪漫旅程的哪个阶段，治疗都是很棒的，因为你有人可以倾诉，
get advice from, kind of help you determine what you want and take some of that pressure off yourself. Yeah, and maybe to help unpack some elements of the past that might be holding you back, well, BetterHelp therapists work according to a strict code of conduct. They are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp will offer you the therapist match commitment. You get a short questionnaire, you say your preferences, and they'll match you with someone. But guess what? if you don't like them, you can switch to a different therapist at any time. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally.
寻求建议，帮助你确定你想要什么，并减轻你身上的一些压力。是的，也许还可以帮助解开过去可能阻碍你的一些因素，嗯，BetterHelp 治疗师按照严格的行为准则工作。他们在美国拥有完全的执照。BetterHelp 将为你提供治疗师匹配承诺。你填写一份简短的问卷，说明你的偏好，他们会为你匹配一个人。但猜猜怎么着？如果你不喜欢他们，你可以随时更换不同的治疗师。拥有超过 30,000 名治疗师，BetterHelp 是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，已为全球超过 500 万人提供服务。
Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHELP.com slash office ladies. 2025 was a great year for TV, movies, and music, and we are highlighting the best of the best, including K-pop demon hunters, and severance. We're talking about our favorite moments of the year, including some of the best pop culture you might have missed. Listen to pop culture happy hour wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, dokey, we are back, and I have to point out one thing before we get into the episode
注册并在 betterhelp.com/officeladies 获得 10% 的折扣。那是 BetterHELP.com/officeladies。2025 年对电视、电影和音乐来说是伟大的一年，我们正在重点介绍最好的作品，包括 K-pop 恶魔猎手和《Severance》。我们正在谈论我们今年最喜欢的时刻，包括一些你可能错过的最好的流行文化。在任何你获取播客的地方收听《Pop Culture Happy Hour》。好的，我们回来了，在进入这一集剖析之前，我必须指出一件事。
breakdown. What is it? I'm to see if you notice. Listeners, you won't be able to see this, but my lady over Zoom is looking at something. I don't know if she's going to notice. I'm flipping through my document that I prepared for the week, and there are no sticky notes, there is nothing like taped? What is it? I did none of my crazy taping pieces of paper and sticky notes. I downloaded the document into a word document. Yes. And I typed in my stuff instead of writing it
是什么？我要看看你是否注意到了。听众们，你们看不到这一点，但我的女士在 Zoom 上看着某样东西。我不知道她是否会注意到。我正在翻阅我为本周准备的文件，没有便利贴，没有像胶带粘着的东西？是什么？我没有做任何我疯狂的粘贴纸条和便利贴的事情。我把文档下载到了 Word 文档中。是的。我输入了我的东西，而不是写在
on stickies and sticking it all over. Modern times. And how did it feel, Angela? To have just pieces of paper without things crafted to it. I really don't know how I feel about it. I really don't know how I feel about it. it. I'm really on the fence and I'll tell you why I did it. You guys, this isn't really how my brain works. I am a sticky note person. I stick them all over the place. But here's the thing. You guys know that I'm currently sitting in my husband's closet. On a tiny table, we drug in from one of the boys' bedrooms. It's like not even an actual desk. That means I have no countertop. I have no place for note cards and all my little pieces of paper I like. I loved it when we were in the studio. Hopefully we'll be able to back there. But because of counterspace, it forced me to become more tech savvy and type it all into
便利贴上并贴得到处都是。现代时代。感觉如何，Angela？只有纸片而没有粘着东西。我真的不知道我对此感觉如何。我真的不知道我对此感觉如何。我真的很纠结，我会告诉你我为什么这么做。伙计们，这不是我的大脑真正的工作方式。我是个便利贴人。我把它们贴得到处都是。但问题是。你们知道我现在正坐在我丈夫的衣橱里。在一张我们从男孩卧室里拖出来的小桌子上。这甚至不是一张真正的桌子。这意味着我没有台面。我没有地方放笔记卡和我喜欢的所有小纸片。当我们在工作室时，我喜欢它。希望我们能回到那里。但因为台面空间，它迫使我变得更精通技术，并把所有东西都打进
one document. I am also excited to soon get back into the studio, I hope. But I will say, sometimes you had so many note cards that it encroached on my space. And I couldn't even fit an eight and a half by 11 sheet of paper on the desk because of your note cards. So I would love to see some maybe hybrid form. A hybrid for you? Because that'd be super cool for me. But lady, you do you. You bring it every week to the podcast and your method is your method.
一个文档里。我也很兴奋很快能回到工作室，我希望。但我会说，有时你有太多的笔记卡，以至于侵占了我的空间。因为你的笔记卡，我甚至不能在桌子上放一张 8.5 x 11 的纸。所以我很想看到某种混合形式。为你准备的混合形式？因为那对我来说会很酷。但女士，做你自己。你每周都给播客带来精彩内容，你的方法就是你的方法。
And I support it even if it means I don't have room for a single sheet of paper. Well, I had to call it out because if I completely suck in this episode, it's because I don't have my stickies. And I'm like, wait, what did I write? Where's that? Oh, my God. Yeah. So let's kick it off.
即使这意味着我没有空间放一张纸，我也支持它。好吧，我必须把它说出来，因为如果我在这一集中表现得很烂，那是因为我没有我的便利贴。我就像，等等，我写了什么？那在哪里？哦，天哪。是的。所以让我们开始吧。
At one second, we have a. blooming planet reception. Another bloom. A beautiful pinkish bloom. I don't know what it is. Michael enters in a huff. He's disheveled. His hair looks weird. Yes, we find out that he saw something shiny under Stanley's car. He wiggled under the car to try and get it and in the process got gum in his hair. Yeah. And now Dwight's on the case. How do we get the gum out of the hair? Pam mentions there's peanut butter in the kitchen. Not the good peanut butter, though, she says. Yeah, people get mad. Don't use the organic peanut butter, but that's what Dwight uses. He slathers it all over Michael's head. I mean, obviously, we're parents. We know you just have to put it on the gum part. You don't have to
在第一秒，我们有一个盛开的植物接待处。又一朵花。一朵美丽的粉红色花朵。我不知道它是什么。Michael 气冲冲地进来了。他衣衫不整。他的头发看起来很奇怪。是的，我们发现他在 Stanley 的车下看到了闪亮的东西。他钻到车下试图把它拿出来，在这个过程中头发里粘了口香糖。是的。现在 Dwight 在处理这件事。我们怎么把口香糖从头发里弄出来？Pam 提到厨房里有花生酱。她说，不是好的那种花生酱。是的，人们会生气。别用有机花生酱，但那就是 Dwight 用的。他把它涂满了 Michael 的头。我是说，显然，我们是父母。我们知道你只需要把它涂在口香糖的部分。你不需要
like shampoo your hair with peanut butter. And then he starts massaging his scalp. I mean, Dwight puts it all over his head. It's ridiculous. So I couldn't help but wonder, Jenna, what was that stuff that they put on Steve's head? What was that? Well, you're not the only person with that question, Angela. Emily, Kira, Leslie, and Ziana also wrote in asking, what did they put on Steve's hair? And I will tell you, it was real peanut butter. But Rain did not put it on Steve's head. It was our hairstylist Kim Ferry. She would get it all set. And then Rain would step in and just do kind of like that last little touch and then do the massaging part. And then she'd have to fix it between takes. And I found out that it's, only took a few takes to get this part of the scene. And afterwards, they scheduled a scene that Steve was not in so that he could go back to the hair and makeup trailer and get his hair all washed out. Kim had to like shampoo it. Oh yeah. In our hair and makeup trailer, you guys, they had like a traditional, you know, in a hair salon that sink you lean back in because it's got the little divot cut out.
像用花生酱洗头一样。然后他开始按摩他的头皮。我是说，Dwight 把它涂满了他的头。这太荒谬了。所以我忍不住想，Jenna，他们涂在 Steve 头上的那东西是什么？那是什么？嗯，Angela，你不是唯一有这个问题的人。Emily、Kira、Leslie 和 Ziana 也写信问，他们往 Steve 的头发上涂了什么？我会告诉你，那是真正的花生酱。但 Rain 没有把它涂在 Steve 的头上。那是我们的发型师 Kim Ferry。她会把它全部准备好。然后 Rain 会走进来，做那种最后的润色，然后做按摩的部分。然后她必须在拍摄间隙修复它。我发现，这一场景只拍了几次就完成了。之后，他们安排了一个 Steve 不在的场景，这样他就可以回到发型和化妆拖车，把头发洗干净。Kim 不得不帮他洗头。哦，是的。在我们的发型和化妆拖车里，伙计们，他们有像传统的，你知道，在美发沙龙里那种你向后靠的洗头槽，因为它有一个小凹槽。
You know, yeah, they had a thing like that. So they could wash your hair if you needed your hair washed. But the water was not very warm. Oh, it was ice cold. Yeah. Well, Angela, I'll have you know that I did a mini deep dive on the best ways to get gum out of your hair. Look at you, lady, you go. Well, peanut butter is the number one recommended solution for gum and hair, but I did find more. Everybody, listen up. You can also use baby oil, cooking oil, Vaseline, adhesive remover, mayonnaise, baking soda with water, lemon juice, white vinegar, ice. I guess you can freeze it out and then it breaks up. But here was my personal favorite.
你知道，是的，他们有那样的东西。所以如果需要洗头，他们可以帮你洗。但水不是很热。哦，那是冰冷的。是的。嗯，Angela，我得让你知道，我对把口香糖从头发里弄出来的最好方法做了一个小小的深入研究。看看你，女士，你真行。嗯，花生酱是口香糖粘在头发上最推荐的解决方案，但我发现了更多。大家，听好了。你也可以使用婴儿油、食用油、凡士林、粘合剂去除剂、蛋黄酱、小苏打加水、柠檬汁、白醋、冰。我想你可以把它冻住，然后它就会碎掉。但这是我个人的最爱。
And I know my dad loves it too. WD40. I mean, there's just, there's nothing WD40 can't do. It solves every problem. You know what? I felt the same way when you said Vaseline. That was our family go-to. I mean, just put some Vaseline on it.
而且我知道我爸爸也喜欢它。WD40。我是说，没有什么 WD40 做不到的。它能解决所有问题。你知道吗？当你提到凡士林时，我有同样的感觉。那是我们家的首选。我是说，只要在上面涂点凡士林。
You know, if you just have some baby oil Vaseline, Vaseline and WD 40 in your house, you can solve almost every problem. Yeah, you're set. So that was our cold open. Now we're going to get into the episode. Michael arrives at work. And I guess he had a date last night because Dwight asked him how it went. We find out it did not go well. Actually, he shares that none of his dates have been going well and he feels like they all lack a bit of a certain Crawfordness. Yeah. But there's more bad news. Everyone finds out that they have to come in on Saturday. And this is not a joke this time. This is not Michael setting the stage for a dinner party trap. This is real. We have to work on Saturday. Yeah, Oscar is livid. Angela says it's ridiculous.
你知道，如果你家里只有一些婴儿油、凡士林、凡士林和 WD40，你几乎可以解决所有问题。是的，你准备好了。所以那是我们的冷开场。现在我们要进入这一集。Michael 到达工作地点。我想他昨晚有个约会，因为 Dwight 问他进展如何。我们发现进展并不顺利。事实上，他分享说他的约会都不顺利，他觉得它们都缺乏某种 Crawford 特质。是的。但还有更多坏消息。每个人都发现他们必须在周六来上班。这次不是开玩笑。这不是 Michael 为晚餐派对陷阱设置的舞台。这是真的。我们周六必须工作。是的，Oscar 很愤怒。Angela 说这太荒谬了。
There's a lot of hubbub in the bullpen because they find out on Saturday they're going to have to take all of their hard work, all of the sales they made, and they're going to have to give the credit to the website. They're going to log it all in as if the website did it. Yeah. Jenna, there's a scene in accounting. You know, Oscar's saying he's livid. Angela says this is ridiculous. There is a series of deleted scenes. Jenna, it's a runner between Pam and Angela. What is it? Well, apparently, for whatever reason, this is one of those days where Angela just hates Pam. Like, just the sound of your voice. Okay, so Angela and Oscar are talking and Pam pokes her head over the partition, right? She wants to get in on the convo. And this is what Angela says.
办公区里有很多骚动，因为他们发现周六他们必须把所有的辛勤工作，所有的销售额，都交给网站。他们要把这一切都记录下来，就好像是网站做的一样。是的。Jenna，会计部有一个场景。你知道，Oscar 说他很愤怒。Angela 说这太荒谬了。有一系列删除的场景。Jenna，这是 Pam 和 Angela 之间的一个小插曲。是什么？嗯，显然，不管什么原因，这是 Angela 讨厌 Pam 的日子之一。就像，只是你声音的音调。好吧，所以 Angela 和 Oscar 在谈话，Pam 把头探过隔板，对吧？她想加入谈话。这就是 Angela 说的。
Sam, can you play the clip? So it's definite? Looks like it. Shoot. Jim and I were going to go to the Cherry Blossom Festival this weekend. I'm sorry. Your voice over my head like that? Sorry.
Sam，你能播放那个片段吗？所以是肯定的？看起来是这样。该死。Jim 和我这个周末本来要去樱花节的。抱歉。你的声音在我头上那样？抱歉。
Isn't that hilarious? Like, just your voice behind me was more than I could take. Now that I hear that, I remember shooting that. There's going to be another one. I'm going to save it for later. So Ryan has delivered this news, and he's being super upbeat about it, but Jim's going to confront him in the kitchen. Yeah. Jim's like, hey man, you mind if I run something by you? Ryan, of course, is in his like super, he's just a lot in this episode. He's like, love it. Go. Right? And Jim's like, I kind of feel like what we have going for us is our customer service. And no matter how we change this up, I don't know that a website's going to be able to replace that. Ryan goes, I can tell you thought a lot about this.
那不是很搞笑吗？就像，你在我身后的声音是我无法忍受的。现在我听到了，我记得拍摄那个场景。还会有另一个。我要把它留到以后。所以 Ryan 传达了这个消息，他对此非常乐观，但 Jim 要在厨房里和他对质。是的。Jim 说，嘿伙计，你介意我跟你说点什么吗？Ryan 当然处于他那种超级，他在这一集中真是太多了。他说，喜欢它。说吧。对吧？Jim 说，我有点觉得我们拥有的优势是我们的客户服务。无论我们怎么改变，我不知道网站是否能取代这一点。Ryan 说，我看得出你对此想了很多。
I appreciate that. Thanks. David Wallace does too. You told him at the Christmas party, right? Jim's like, uh, and Ryan's like, yeah, watch your back, Jim. I'm just kidding. Yeah. I mean, Ryan has it out for Jim. You know, here's a bit of trivia.
我很感激。谢谢。David Wallace 也是。你在圣诞派对上告诉过他，对吧？Jim 说，呃，Ryan 说，是的，小心你的背后，Jim。我开玩笑的。是的。我是说，Ryan 对 Jim 有意见。你知道，这里有一个小花絮。
We would have had a Christmas episode, but we didn't because of the writer's strike. I know I'm so bummed about that. Yeah. So that's why this season does not have a Christmas episode. Yeah. Well, now we move into the conference. room and Michael, this really made me laugh. He's sort of trying to sympathize with Ryan why people are feeling resentful towards Ryan. And then he makes this speech. And Jenna, I could not imagine being
我们本来会有一集圣诞特辑，但因为编剧罢工我们没有。我知道我对此很沮丧。是的。所以这就是为什么这一季没有圣诞特辑。是的。嗯，现在我们进入会议室，Michael，这真的让我笑了。他试图同情 Ryan，为什么人们对 Ryan 感到不满。然后他发表了演讲。Jenna，我无法想象被我的老板介绍参加这样的会议。女士们先生们，请注意。我知道你们很多人对 Ryan 很生气，因为他是我们明天必须来上班的原因。然而，我向上帝发誓，如果你们中有人在情感上伤害他，或者嘲笑他，或者取笑他的身高或他的半截胡子，或者我喜欢他的半截胡子。我知道如果你取笑他的半截胡子。我看到 Oscar 开始破功了。那太大了。是的。
introduced by my boss for a meeting like this. Ladies and gentlemen, may I have your attention, please. I know that a lot of you are very angry with Ryan because he is the reason we all have to come in tomorrow. However, I swear to God, if any of you hurts him in any way emotionally, are or taunts him or makes fun of his height or his half beard or I love his half beard. I know if you make fun of his half beard. I saw Oscar start to break. That's huge. Yes.
但我非常了解 Oscar 的破功，因为我们在整个节目期间都坐在一起。所以当某件事让他发笑但他试图不笑时，他会做的一件事就是他会做这个小动作，他的头会稍微点一下。伙计们，这太细微了。这太细微了。但当 Michael 说到胡子的部分时，Oscar 做了那个点头的小动作。我就像，哦，Oscar，我看到你了。在他可爱的介绍之后，Ryan 开始非常热情地捍卫 Dunder Mifflin 2.0。
But I know Oscars tells so well because we sat next to each other for the whole run of the show. So one of the things he does when something makes him laugh but he's trying not to laugh is he does this little thing with his head where he kind of nods his head down. And it's so slight, you guys. It's so slight. But when Michael says the part about the beard, Oscar does that little head nod thing. And I was like, oh, Oscar, I see you. After his lovely introduction, Ryan starts defending Dunder Mifflin 2.0, very passionately.
是的，他一直在说。他知道网站被黑了。他试图捍卫它。Jenna，在他演讲时我有一个会议桌的发现。什么？4 分 30 秒。会议桌上有两个咖啡杯。猜猜是谁的？
Yeah, and he's going on and on. He knows the website was hacked. He's trying to defend it. Jenna, I have a conference table catch during his speech. What? Four minutes, 30 seconds. There are two coffee mugs on the conference table. Any guesses who's they are?
嗯，其中一个是 Pam 的粉色杯子，因为我看到了。我没注意到另一个，因为我在看大型群戏时只看我自己。但我确实看到我有我的杯子。Jim 也有。哦。没有其他人有咖啡杯。只有 Jim 和 Pam。我开始想，除了派对，你什么时候见过有人在会议室里拿着饮料？
Well, one of them is Pam's pink mug because I saw it. I did not notice another one because I only look at myself when I'm watching big group scenes. But I did see that I had my mug. So does Jim. Oh. No one else has a coffee mug. Just Jim and Pam. And I started thinking, when did you ever see anyone with a beverage in the conference room except a party?
一直都有。我总是把我的杯子带进会议室，Angela，因为我可以在场景中喝咖啡。这对我来说是一件大事。所以你知道吗？你可能没穿连裤袜，但你也没想到带饮料进房间。哦，天哪。
All the time. I always brought my mug into the conference room, Angela, because I could actually drink coffee during the scene. It was a big thing for me. So you know what? You maybe didn't wear your panty hose, but you also didn't think to bring a beverage into the room. Oh my gosh.
嗯，我想我对 Pam 拿着杯子有点记忆，但我不敢相信。他们都有杯子。我很嫉妒。哦，John 和我一直在讨论我们怎么能在工作中喝咖啡。所以，是的，别担心。你现在会经常看到这一点。既然你已经发现了一次，
Well, I guess I kind of have memories of Pam holding her mug, but I couldn't believe it. They both had mugs. I was jealous. Oh, John and I were all over the how can we drink coffee at work. So, yeah, don't worry. You're going to see that a lot now. Now that you've spotted it once,
嗯，我想我确实记得帕姆拿着马克杯的样子，但我简直不敢相信。他们俩都有马克杯。我很嫉妒。哦，约翰和我一直在讨论我们怎么能在工作时喝咖啡。所以，是的，别担心。你现在会经常看到这种情况了。既然你已经发现了一次，
it's going to be something you can never unsee. All right, guys. we have something new to track. Who's drinking coffee in conference room scenes? Well, one of my favorite moments in this conference room scene, Angela, is Mindy's line when she says, I have a lot of questions. Number one, how dare you? I loved it so much.
这会成为你永远无法忘怀的画面。好了，各位。我们有新的东西要追踪了。谁在会议室场景里喝咖啡？嗯，安吉拉，在这个会议室场景里，我最喜欢的时刻之一是敏迪的台词，她说：“我有很多问题。第一，你怎么敢？”我太喜欢这一幕了。
We got a fan question from Jocelyn Sumi, who said, this is the line that is most quoted by my family, so I have to know who wrote it. Please tell me it was Mindy Kaling. Yes, Mindy wrote this line. and she was asked about this line in an interview she did with office tally, and I loved her answer. Oh, let's hear it. Here's what she said, quote, I never intentionally give myself the funniest lines. However, they often resonate as the funniest because of my gifts as a comic actor.
我们收到了乔斯林·苏米的粉丝提问，她说：“这是我家引用最多的一句台词，所以我必须知道是谁写的。请告诉我那是敏迪·卡灵写的。”是的，敏迪写了这句台词。她在接受《办公室统计》采访时被问及这句台词，我非常喜欢她的回答。哦，让我们听听。她是这么说的，引用：“我从不刻意给自己安排最搞笑的台词。然而，由于我作为喜剧演员的天赋，它们往往会产生最搞笑的效果。”
Sometimes I try to give myself really drab unfunny lines so as to not steal focus, but even that doesn't work because they always sparkle upon delivery. It's hard. It's hard being so fabulous, y'all. But I just loved that. I thought it was really funny. That is really funny. I had a friend when I lived in New York in my 20s, and whenever she'd get a little tipsy, inevitably, she'd say, how dare you?
有时我试着给自己一些非常枯燥、不好笑的台词，以免抢了风头，但即使那样也不管用，因为它们一说出来总是会闪闪发光。这很难。做一个如此迷人的人真的很难，各位。但我就是喜欢这一点。我觉得这真的很有趣。那确实很有趣。我二十多岁住在纽约时有个朋友，每当她喝得有点微醺，她不可避免地会说：“你怎么敢？”
Like, we'd be like, hey, listen, we got to go. Let's get in the cab. Get in the cab. You know what? How dare you? I'm like, okay, you've had enough. That was her tell. Yeah, that was her tell.
就像我们说：“嘿，听着，我们得走了。上出租车吧。上车。”她会说：“你知道吗？你怎么敢？”我就想：“好吧，你喝得够多了。”那是她的标志。是的，那是她的标志。
How dare you? What? I just asked you to grab your purse. How dare you? Okay, okay. I have to say another one of my favorite parts of this scene is the slow clap by Michael. Oh! He leads a slow clap as a way of defending Ryan, and I do love it.
“你怎么敢？”什么？我只是让你拿上你的钱包。你怎么敢？好吧，好吧。我必须说，这个场景中我最喜欢的另一个部分是迈克尔的慢动作鼓掌。哦！他带头慢动作鼓掌，以此来维护瑞安，我真的很喜欢。
I thought it was a very bold choice by Michael. That's like an iconic movie moment. So you know I had to do a mini dive on the slow clap in movies, because they are always amazing. They never, ever cease to not be amazing. When I went on IMDB and looked up how many movies had a slow clap, there's like a hundred. There's like so many movies. Jenna, sports movies have slow claps.
我觉得这是迈克尔一个非常大胆的选择。那就像电影里的经典时刻。所以你知道我必须对电影里的慢动作鼓掌做一个小小的深入研究，因为它们总是很棒。它们永远、永远不会不精彩。当我在IMDB上搜索有多少电影有慢动作鼓掌时，大概有一百部。有太多的电影了。珍娜，体育电影里有慢动作鼓掌。
Like law dramatic movies have slow claps. Comedies have sarcastic slow claps. There are slow claps in every genre. I remember very clearly my introduction to the slow clap. I remember the first movie that I watched with a slow clap. Oh, lady, we all know the first movie we saw a slow clap in. I mean, what was yours? Can't Buy Me Love with Patrick Dempsey.
像法律剧情片里有慢动作鼓掌。喜剧里有讽刺性的慢动作鼓掌。每个类型片里都有慢动作鼓掌。我非常清楚地记得我第一次接触慢动作鼓掌。我记得我看的第一个有慢动作鼓掌的电影。哦，女士，我们都知道我们第一次看到慢动作鼓掌的电影是什么。我是说，你的是哪部？帕特里克·德姆西主演的《情人节情人》。
Yes, absolutely. Famous slow clap at the tables outside. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Oh, yeah. So first of all, I thought the slow clap was like an 80s, 90s movie thing because I remembered it from movies like Lucas, Cool Runnings, Officer and a Gentleman, scent of a woman, Rudy.
是的，绝对是。桌子外面的著名慢动作鼓掌。嗯哼。是的。哦，是的。所以首先，我以为慢动作鼓掌是80、90年代电影的东西，因为我记得它出现在像《卢卡斯》、《冰上轻舞》、《军官与绅士》、《闻香识女人》、《追梦赤子心》这样的电影里。
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I have to stop you. There's a slow clap in Officer and a Gentleman and a Gentleman and Sent of a Woman. Yes. Oh, scent of a woman. It happens in the courtroom. No. Officer and a gentleman, it happens in the factory. Yes. I'm sorry, because it's shocking me because I really only associate the slow clap with 80s teen movies. That's why I was freaking out. They're in dramas. They're everywhere, lady, especially in sports movies. Okay. Rudy. Who's Revenge of the Nerds, The Breakfast Club, Can't Buy Me Love, as you said, not another teen movie, Varsity Blues. Get ready for this one. Jersey Girl. Wow. Jersey Girl with Ben Affleck. Anyway, the list goes on and on, you guys. And I really thought it all started in the 80s and 90s, but according to the internet, I was wrong. The very first slow clap was in 1968 in a movie called The Lion in Winter, starring Peter O'Toole as Henry II, he slow claps to Catherine Hepburn as Eleanor of Aquitaine after her dramatic plea. Wow. I know. I feel like there are subcategories of slow claps. Ernest, sarcastic. Joyous, rally the troops. Yes, inspirational slow clap.
等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。我得打断你。在《军官与绅士》和《闻香识女人》里有慢动作鼓掌吗？是的。哦，《闻香识女人》。它发生在法庭上。不。《军官与绅士》，它发生在工厂里。是的。对不起，因为这让我很震惊，因为我真的只把慢动作鼓掌和80年代的青春片联系在一起。这就是我为什么会抓狂。它们出现在剧情片里。它们无处不在，女士，特别是在体育电影里。好吧。《追梦赤子心》。还有《阿呆与阿瓜》、《早餐俱乐部》、《情人节情人》，正如你所说，《非常男女》、《校园蓝调》。准备好听这个。 《泽西女孩》。哇。《泽西女孩》里有本·阿弗莱克。总之，名单还在继续，各位。我真的以为这一切始于80和90年代，但根据互联网的说法，我错了。第一次慢动作鼓掌是在1968年的电影《冬狮》中，由彼得·奥图尔饰演亨利二世，他在凯瑟琳·赫本饰演的阿基坦的埃莉诺发表了戏剧性的恳求后，对她进行了慢动作鼓掌。哇。我知道。我觉得慢动作鼓掌有细分类别。真诚的，讽刺的。欢乐的，鼓舞士气的。是的，励志的慢动作鼓掌。
Angry, smart-ass slow clap. Thank you for doing that. You're welcome. Well, I found that fascinating, Angela. Moving on, I don't know if you want to track this, the lingering hug. Oh. Because that's like the slow clap, a thing. Michael is going to employ a lingering hug with Ryan as he says goodbye.
愤怒的、自以为是的慢动作鼓掌。谢谢你做这些。不客气。嗯，我觉得这很迷人，安吉拉。继续，我不知道你是否想追踪这个，缠绵的拥抱。哦。因为那就像慢动作鼓掌一样，是一回事。迈克尔在告别时要对瑞安使用缠绵的拥抱。
And he's just going to say, like, dude, do you know any women you could set me up with in New York? And Ryan says, I don't know anyone. specifically, but the women in the clubs in New York are amazing. This is going to give Michael ideas. You can't say something like that to Michael? No. He decides to ask Jim if he'd like to go clubbing. Well, I should say he leads that conversation by asking Jim if he would ever have sex with
他只是会说：“伙计，你认识什么可以在纽约给我介绍的女性吗？”瑞安说：“我不认识任何人。具体来说，但纽约夜店里的女性很棒。”这会给迈克尔一些想法。你不能对迈克尔说那样的话？不。他决定问吉姆是否想去夜店。嗯，我应该说他引导那段对话的方式是问吉姆他是否会和
Meredith and if he thinks Meredith can be discreet. But then that leads to do you want to go clubbing with me in New York? Because they're both single. Right. And Jim's like. I'm dating bam. And Michael says, oh, that's still going on? What? So, of course, now Michael has to enlist Dwight and Andy wants to go. He says the old ball and chain has been more chain than ball lately. You know what I mean? I don't know what that means, but gross me out. And Angela says, I'm right here. Jenna? Yeah. I would like to call this moment. Hello, Super Preggs. Six minutes, 52 seconds. I'm standing at front reception. And you can clearly. see my maternity shirt hanging out from under my sweater. I saw it. Uh-huh. And there's a whole blooper
梅雷迪思发生性关系，以及他是否认为梅雷迪思能守口如瓶。但那导致了“你想和我一起去纽约的夜店吗？”因为他们都是单身。对。吉姆说：“我在和帕姆约会。”迈克尔说：“哦，那还在继续吗？什么？”所以，当然，现在迈克尔必须拉上德怀特，安迪也想去。他说：“那个老球和链子最近链子比球多。”你知道我的意思吗？我不知道那是什么意思，但让我觉得恶心。安吉拉说：“我就在这儿。”珍娜？是的。我想把这个时刻称为“你好，超级孕妇”。6分52秒。我站在前台。你可以清楚地
that happens right here where I come around from the copier laughing, itching, scratching my enormous belly. Well, this all sets the stage for what is going to become Michael and Dwight hitting the town in New York. They found out from Ryan's assistant that he would be at a club called prerogative. It's the happiest Ryan has ever been to see Michael or Dwight. It's such a funny line because he's so excited to see them that Michael says, Ryan, it's Michael and Dwight. He's like, I think maybe you haven't seen me clearly. Yeah.
看到我的孕妇装从毛衣下面露出来。我看到了。嗯哼。这里有一个完整的花絮，
He's like, I know what you guys. And Michael's like, okay. Jenna, at 8 minutes, 24 seconds, if you love to spot some fun stuff in the background, there's some fantastic background dancing by a guy and a blue button down. He's having the time of his life. I love it. This is also when Ryan is going to introduce us to his friend Troy, and Dwight says, you look like a hobbit.
发生在这里，我从复印机旁边笑着走出来，抓着、挠着我巨大的肚子。嗯，这一切为迈克尔和德怀特在纽约城里逛街奠定了基础。他们从瑞安的助理那里得知他会在一家叫“特权”的夜店。这是瑞安见到迈克尔或德怀特时最开心的一次。这句台词太搞笑了，因为他见到他们太兴奋了，以至于迈克尔说：“瑞安，是迈克尔和德怀特。”他就像是：“我想也许你没看清我。”是的。
He's actually become sort of obsessed with the idea that Troy might actually be from the world of the Lord of the Rings. This is the crazy thing about Dwight, and he does this again and again throughout the show, where he actually believes in some of this fantastical genre. You know, like, it's crazy to me, but he's earnest. He really believes he might be a hobbit and have special powers. Yes.
他就像是：“我知道你们是谁。”迈克尔说：“好吧。”珍娜，在8分24秒，如果你喜欢在背景里发现一些有趣的东西，有一个穿蓝色扣领衬衫的家伙在进行精彩的背景舞蹈。他玩得非常开心。我喜欢。这也是瑞安要向我们介绍他的朋友特洛伊的时候，德怀特说：“你看起来像个霍比特人。”
And of course, anyone with special powers is of great interest to Dwight. Yeah. I was really charmed, Angela, by Michael's inability to understand what a bottle service waitress does. This reminded me of you and I when we did go to one nightclub and experienced bottle service one time in our lives? What a joke, okay? Like everyone was like, oh, bottle service. And Jen and I were like, okay, we'd never done this. It's like $200 or something. I just remember we got the bill and we're like what. And they light up this little like sparklers. They have sparklers and they walk over with a big tray of all of this different type of vodka or something and mixers. Jen and I
他实际上已经有点痴迷于特洛伊可能真的来自《指环王》世界的想法了。这就是德怀特疯狂的地方，他在整个节目中一次又一次地这样做，他实际上相信这些奇幻类型中的一些东西。你知道，这对我来说很疯狂，但他很真诚。他真的相信他可能是个霍比特人，拥有特殊能力。是的。
don't drink any of that stuff. So it was like, what's the point? I was hoping. there'd be snacks or something? No. Like Michael's same problem. There's no snacks. It's just a tray of liquor bottles and mixers. And then here's the thing. Angela, it's $200, but then you have to make your own drinks. What's the point of that? I just wanted a cosmopolitan from the bartender. But now I'm trying to make my own drink. I barely know what I'm doing. I was very Michael Scott. I'll say that. I would have loved a glass of maraschino cherries. Just to eat. them. I was so hungry. I would have loved some chicken fingers and a glass of wine, but now we have sparklers for $200. I don't know if you guys noticed, but Michael wanted to order a Midori sour,
当然，任何有特殊能力的人都会引起德怀特的极大兴趣。是的。安吉拉，迈克尔无法理解瓶装服务女服务员是做什么的，这让我很着迷。这让我想起了你和我，当我们确实去过一家夜店，体验过一次我们生命中的瓶装服务？真是个笑话，好吧？就像每个人都说：“哦，瓶装服务。”珍娜和我当时想：“好吧，我们从来没做过这个。”大概要200美元什么的。我只记得我们拿到账单时，我们想：“什么？”他们点亮了这种像小烟花的东西。他们有烟花，然后走过来，带着一大盘各种各样的伏特加或什么东西，还有调酒饮料。珍娜和我
which I thought was an amazing callback to the convention season three. Yeah. Remember when Jim and Josh had that inside joke, a shot of Midori, perhaps? I still think Michael thinks that's a drink that you order when you want to be fancy because of Jim and Josh. This is a way Michael and I are similar. I would also grab on to a story like that and be like, okay, wait, so when I'm in the club to be cool, order Midori Sour. Got it. And chicken fingers.
不喝那些东西。所以就像，有什么意义？我当时希望有零食什么的？没有。就像迈克尔同样的问题。没有零食。只有一盘酒瓶和调酒饮料。然后事情是这样的。安吉拉，要200美元，但你必须自己调酒。那有什么意义？我只是想从调酒师那里要一杯大都会鸡尾酒。但现在我得试着自己调酒。我几乎不知道我在做什么。我当时非常像迈克尔·斯科特。我会这么说。我本来会喜欢一杯马拉斯奇诺樱桃。只是为了吃。它们。我太饿了。我本来会喜欢一些鸡柳和一杯葡萄酒，但现在我们花了200美元买了烟花。我不知道你们有没有注意到，但迈克尔想点一杯蜜瓜酸酒，
But there's no chicken fingers. You're just going to get a cup of olives. So meanwhile, back in the office, Jim has some ideas. He's a real idea man, even after the whole birthday thing blew up in his face. His big idea is that if everyone stays late for you. just a few hours, then they won't have to come in tomorrow. Jim, I hope you were thorough when you decided to suggest this and that you crossed all your T's and dotted your eyes because I'm sure people are still pissed off at you about the cakes. I have some news for you. Angela,
我觉得这是对第三季会议的一个很棒的回应。是的。还记得吉姆和乔什有那个内部笑话吗，“也许来一杯蜜瓜酒？”我仍然认为迈克尔认为那是当你想要显得时髦时点的饮料，因为吉姆和乔什。这是迈克尔和我相似的一种方式。我也会抓住那样的故事，然后想：“好吧，等等，所以当我在夜店里为了显得酷，点蜜瓜酸酒。明白了。”还有鸡柳。
he did not do any of that. It turns out that everyone stayed late and then at 9 p.m., when they decide to leave, they discover that they are locked into the parking lot. Yes, lady, there is a fantastic group shot at 8 minutes 48 seconds, where it pans everyone as they realize they're locked in. And I just want you to know, at this point, I have reached the point in my pregnancy where I can no longer button up my coat and my purse is no longer really hiding my belly. I have more news for you. Not only is the parking gate locked such that they cannot leave, they also cannot return to the comfort of the office because Pam has locked the door from the inside, She doesn't have a key.
但没有鸡柳。你只会得到一杯橄榄。所以与此同时，回到办公室，吉姆有一些想法。他是个真正的点子王，即使在整个生日事件在他脸上炸开之后。他的大点子是，如果每个人都为你多待一会儿，哪怕只是几个小时，那么他们明天就不必来了。吉姆，我希望你在决定建议这个时很彻底，并且你把所有的T都划了，所有的I都点了，因为我肯定人们还在因为蛋糕的事生你的气。我有个消息要告诉你。安吉拉，
Pam has a talking head that is so great. She said that Dwight has both the master and spare key. And when she asked him how they'd get into the office if he ever died, he responded with, Jenna, you say it. If I'm dead, you guys have been dead for weeks. Yeah. Okay, Dwight. Okay. Yeah.
他根本没做那些事。结果每个人都待得很晚，然后在晚上9点，当他们决定离开时，他们发现他们被锁在停车场里了。是的，女士，在8分48秒有一个精彩的集体镜头，当每个人意识到他们被锁在里面时，镜头扫过了每个人。我只想让你知道，此时此刻，我已经到了怀孕的阶段，我再也扣不上我的外套了，我的钱包也不再能真正遮住我的肚子了。我还有更多消息要告诉你。不仅停车门被锁住，导致他们无法离开，他们也无法回到舒适的办公室，因为帕姆从里面锁上了门，她没有钥匙。
One of my favorite lines in all of this is Stanley when he declares that if he is not in his bath with a glass of wine within the hour, they're both dead. Now, Jenna, that line to me was the closest to Leslie David Baker in real life than any other line he ever said on the show. Because he and I would talk about how we couldn't wait to get home and take a bath. With a glass of wine! With a glass of wine. You know, like soak our muscles. Yes, I thought the same thing, Angela.
帕姆有一个非常棒的访谈镜头。她说德怀特既有主钥匙也有备用钥匙。当她问他如果他死了他们怎么进办公室时，他回答说——珍娜，你说出来。如果我死了，你们都已经死了好几周了。是的。好吧，德怀特。好吧。是的。
Well, they get an idea. It's very simple. All we have to do is call the security guard and ask him to come unlock the gate. Yeah, but no one has his phone number and no one can remember his name. Yeah, no one can remember his name, but Toby has his phone number. He has his phone number, but he did not enter his name with the phone number into his phone. So we still have the name dilemma, but Toby does save the day, and Pam is very impressed. And it's probably Toby's happiest moment in his whole entire life.
在所有这些中，我最喜欢的台词之一是斯坦利，当他宣称如果他不能在一小时内泡在浴缸里喝上一杯葡萄酒，他们两个都得死。现在，珍娜，那句台词对我来说，比他在节目中说的任何其他台词都更接近现实生活中的莱斯利·大卫·贝克。因为他和我会谈论我们是多么迫不及待地想回家泡个澡。喝上一杯葡萄酒！喝上一杯葡萄酒。你知道，就像放松我们的肌肉。是的，我想的一样，安吉拉。
Yes. It's going to lead him to make a mistake later, but we'll get there. Some really big swings are about to come from Toby. We had a fan catch from Ben M and Skyler T. Can we talk about how Creed is the person who knows Hank's name when nobody else seems to know it? He seems like the least likely person who would know anyone's name as it has been established. I just loved that. I loved it and I thought it was actually perfect.
嗯，他们想到了一个主意。这很简单。我们所要做的就是给保安打电话，让他来开门。是的，但没人有他的电话号码，也没人记得他的名字。是的，没人记得他的名字，但托比有他的电话号码。他有他的电话号码，但他没有把他的名字和电话号码输入到他的手机里。所以我们仍然面临名字的困境，但托比确实拯救了局面，帕姆印象非常深刻。这可能是托比一生中最快乐的时刻。
I feel like Creed would know Hank's name. I feel like Creed sort of has a person on the inside wherever he is. I mean, how many times has Hank probably had to let Creed in or out of the building? We know he's slept there many nights. That's right. Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, Dwight is really wowing. Ryan and Troy about weevil season details.
是的。这会导致他以后犯错，但我们会讲到那里的。托比即将做出一些非常大的举动。我们收到了本·M和斯凯勒·T的粉丝捕捉。我们能谈谈为什么克里德是那个知道汉克名字的人，而其他人似乎都不知道吗？他看起来是最不可能知道任何人名字的人，正如已经确立的那样。我太喜欢这一点了。我喜欢它，我觉得它实际上很完美。
That is a great go-to-break description. Well, we're back. Dwight is holding court talking about weevil season. Ryan is kind of jittery. Says he's got to go to the bathroom again. White is positive he might have a UTI. Yeah, he says, I'll order you some cranberry juice. For his urinary track infection.
我觉得克里德会知道汉克的名字。我觉得克里德无论在哪里都有一个内部人员。我是说，汉克可能有多少次不得不让克里德进出大楼？我们知道他在那里睡过很多个晚上。那是对的。好吧，让我们休息一下。当我们回来时，德怀特真的在用象鼻虫季节的细节让瑞安和特洛伊惊叹。
Well, this made me wonder. Oh, no. About UTIs or cranberry juice? Both. Okay. Because this is a thing that women are told will help their UTIs, cranberry juice. I thought it's time to deep dive it. Oh, well, let's hear it.
那是一个很棒的休息描述。好吧，我们回来了。德怀特正在主持谈话，谈论象鼻虫季节。瑞安有点紧张。说他得再去一次洗手间。德怀特肯定他可能得了尿路感染。是的，他说：“我会给你点些蔓越莓汁。”为了他的尿路感染。
Maybe we'll help people today, Jenna. Perhaps. Perhaps after listening to this podcast, you will not only know where, to get a rabies vaccine, but you will also know what to do when you get a UTI. We'll see. Here's the question, does cranberry juice prevent or cure a UTI? One group of researchers tested cranberry juice cocktail, as this is very easy to find. But wait, are there any real cranberries in the cranberry juice cocktail? Yes, there is some. There's also a lot of sugar. However, the researchers discovered that in petri dishes, the cranberry metabolites did prevent
嗯，这让我感到好奇。哦，不。关于尿路感染还是蔓越莓汁？两者都是。好吧。因为这是女性被告知会有助于尿路感染的事情，蔓越莓汁。我想是时候深入研究一下了。哦，好吧，让我们听听。
E. coli from sticking to other bacteria, therefore limiting its ability to grow and multiply. Huh. In petri dishes, cranberry juice cocktail did this. But does that translate to the human body? Unsure. What about the soup or kadoop or cranberry juice that's like all organic? You know, the kind you see at the grocery store that has like sediment. at the bottom because it's like super healthy, just cranberryness.
也许我们今天会帮助人们，珍娜。也许吧。也许听完这个播客后，你不仅会知道去哪里接种狂犬病疫苗，你还会知道当你得了尿路感染时该怎么办。我们会看到的。这是问题所在，蔓越莓汁能预防或治愈尿路感染吗？一组研究人员测试了蔓越莓汁鸡尾酒，因为这很容易找到。但等等，蔓越莓汁鸡尾酒里有真正的蔓越莓吗？是的，有一些。里面也有很多糖。然而，研究人员发现，在培养皿中，蔓越莓代谢物确实阻止了
I wondered the same thing. I could not find a study on that, but I did find a study where they tested cranberry capsules, which would be that same kind of highly concentrated cranberry business. Yeah, yeah. They tested 185 female nursing home residents. They gave them cranberry pills for one year, and they found that there was no statistical significant difference in the presence of bacteria between the people who took the pills and the control group. So at the end of the day, most studies suggest that juice and supplements do not have
大肠杆菌粘附在其他细菌上，从而限制了它的生长和繁殖能力。嗯。在培养皿中，蔓越莓汁鸡尾酒做到了这一点。但这能转化为人体吗？不确定。那像那种全有机的汤或蔓越莓汁呢？你知道，你在杂货店看到的那种，因为它是超级健康的，底部有沉淀物，只是蔓越莓味。
enough of the active ingredient, which is called A-type pro-anthacidioninsens. You heard it. I said it right. Prophacincincininininins. Uh-huh. That's right. To prevent bacteria from sticking to the urinary tract. And therefore, if you think you have an infection, call your doctor, get some antibiotics. And to prevent a UTI, the best things you can do are ladies, wipe front to back, always front to back, pee after sex, and take regular probiotics. I think that's a very solid deep dive on cranberries and UTIs. I hope the listeners of this podcast will experience fewer UTIs and or, get their UTI problems solved more quickly after listening to today's episode. Where do we go from there?
我也想到了同样的问题。我找不到关于那个的研究，但我确实找到了一个研究，他们测试了蔓越莓胶囊，那将是同样那种高度浓缩的蔓越莓产品。是的，是的。他们测试了185名女性疗养院居民。他们给她们吃了为期一年的蔓越莓药丸，他们发现服用药丸的人和对照组之间在细菌存在方面没有统计学上的显著差异。所以归根结底，大多数研究表明果汁和补充剂没有
Well, I guess we could go back to the lobby of Dundermifflin because guess what? Jim got a hold of Hank. Woohoo! Hank is going to be there in under an hour. Oscar says, man, we have to make sure we give him a big tip this Christmas. And that's when they realized that no one tipped him last Christmas. because Jim was supposed to collect the money from everyone. Well, Jim is really on a roll here. Way to go, Jim.
足够的活性成分，也就是所谓的A型原花青素。你听到了。我说对了。原花青素。嗯哼。那是对的。来防止细菌粘附在尿道上。因此，如果你认为你感染了，打电话给你的医生，吃些抗生素。为了预防尿路感染，你能做的最好的事情是，女士们，从前向后擦，总是从前向后，性交后排尿，并服用常规益生菌。我认为这是对蔓越莓和尿路感染的一个非常扎实的深入研究。我希望这个播客的听众在听完今天的节目后，会经历更少的尿路感染和/或更快地解决他们的尿路感染问题。我们从那里去哪里？
Way to go, Jim. You're just ticking everyone off left and right. There are a series of fantastic deleted scenes that all happened in the lobby. There was a much bigger story here, but I think they just ran out of time in the episode. So, you guys, there's a second one of Angela just being annoyed at Pam. Sam, can we hear that? You did it. But I have to walk my cats.
嗯，我想我们可以回到邓德米夫林的大厅，因为猜猜怎么着？吉姆联系上了汉克！呜呼！汉克会在一小时内赶到。奥斯卡说：“伙计，我们必须确保今年圣诞节给他一大笔小费。”就在那时他们意识到去年圣诞节没人给他小费。因为吉姆本应从每个人那里收集钱。嗯，吉姆在这里真的很顺利。干得好，吉姆。
I'm sure they'll be okay for one night. Stop taking his side. We're not all sleeping with Jim. That's not a nice thing to say. You know what's not nice? Unexercised cats. You know what else is not nice? Coming home and looking into your cat's eyes and seeing nothing but disappointment.
干得好，吉姆。你只是在左右惹恼每个人。大厅里发生了一系列精彩的删减场景。这里有一个更大的故事，但我认为他们只是在这一集中没时间了。所以，各位，有第二个安吉拉对帕姆感到恼火的场景。萨姆，我们能听听那个吗？你做到了。但我得去遛我的猫。
That's a bit much, isn't it? I mean, listen to the two of them with their digs back and forth. How about Andy asking everyone to raise their hand and vote on who is the best couple? Pam and Jim or Andy and Angela. And then you all vote for yourselves, by the way, I noticed. Oh, and Phyllis votes for us too. So how about them apples? Well, there are two more deleted scenes from us all being stuck in the lobby and parking lot that I loved.
我相信它们一晚上会没事的。别再站在他那边了。我们不是都在和吉姆睡觉。那不是一句好听的话。你知道什么不好听吗？没锻炼的猫。你还知道什么不好听吗？回家看着你猫的眼睛，看到的只有失望。
One, and Jenna, I remember you guys filming this. I don't know if you remember it. One is where Phyllis, Pam, Oscar, and Toby are all huddled up watching a movie on an iPod. And it's about the Bolin sisters. I do remember that now that you say it. You're holding up like the little headphones each so you can kind of hear. Yes. And you're watching it on an iPod.
那有点过分了，不是吗？我是说，听听他们两个来回的挖苦。安迪让每个人举手投票谁是最好的情侣怎么样？帕姆和吉姆，还是安迪和安吉拉。顺便说一句，我注意到你们都投给了自己。哦，菲利斯也投给了我们。那又怎么样呢？嗯，还有两个删减场景，关于我们都被困在大厅和停车场，我很喜欢。
Do you know how small those screens were? I do remember very tiny. Like about the size of a large postage stamp. Yeah, exactly. And another scene that I loved is that Stanley's wife brings him snacks to the fence. Oh, yeah. And Stanley drinks like a milkshake or something. through the mesh fence using a straw, and it's such a cute scene.
一个，珍娜，我记得你们拍了这个。我不知道你记不记得。一个是菲利斯、帕姆、奥斯卡和托比都挤在一起看iPod上的电影。是关于博林姐妹的。你这么一说我确实记得了。你们每个人都举着小耳机，这样你们就能听到一点。是的。你们在iPod上看它。
A lady, should we go back to the club? Oh, it is not going well in de club. Michael has just talked to a young gal who had never even heard of Back to the Future. So Ryan is like, should we go to a club where there's older girls? And Michael's like, yeah. You know, Angela, this got me thinking this whole club thing. Michael's going to relocate to another club to meet a woman. Why isn't Michael doing online dating, right?
你知道那些屏幕有多小吗？我确实记得非常小。大概像一张大邮票那么大。是的，完全正确。我喜欢的另一个场景是斯坦利的妻子给他带零食到栅栏那里。哦，是的。斯坦利喝着奶昔什么的。通过网状栅栏用吸管，这是一个非常可爱的场景。
They didn't have online dating then. Oh, yes, they did. I looked it up. Oh, you were setting me up. What? Seriously? Well, first of all, in an earlier episode, we saw Michael setting up an online dating profile that we never see him use.
女士，我们应该回到夜店吗？哦，夜店里情况不太好。迈克尔刚刚和一个甚至没听说过《回到未来》的年轻女孩谈过。所以瑞安说：“我们应该去一个有年长女孩的夜店吗？”迈克尔说：“是的。”你知道，安吉拉，这让我思考整个夜店的事情。迈克尔要搬到另一个夜店去见一个女人。为什么迈克尔不进行在线约会，对吧？
But I Googled it. The very first online dating site was called kiss. and it launched in 1994. But it was followed the very next year by Match.com, which sort of took over the whole online dating world. But that was 1995. By this time, Michael would have several options. Ashley Madison came on the scene in 2002.
他们那时没有在线约会。哦，是的，他们有。我查过了。哦，你在给我设套。什么？真的吗？嗯，首先，在之前的一集里，我们看到迈克尔建立了一个在线约会资料，我们从没见他用过。
OKCupid was 2004. Anyway, I'm just saying he had options that weren't driving to New York and going to weird nightclubs with Ryan. Oh, I know all about the dating sites and the apps because Jenna, I went viral because my nephew, who was new to Tinder, his friends were like, you need to have a hook so the gals don't swipe right or left. I don't know Tinder, whatever. They swipe or something, right?
但我谷歌了一下。第一个在线约会网站叫Kiss，它于1994年推出。但第二年紧接着就是Match.com，它在某种程度上接管了整个在线约会世界。但那是1995年。到这个时候，迈克尔会有几个选择。阿什利·麦迪逊在2002年出现在现场。
So my nephew found a family photo that I was in. And he was like, yeah, that's me and my aunt from the office. And it went viral, right? because all of a sudden my face is on Tinder. And I had to call my nephews. I have more than one. And I said, hey, guys, I'm just going to blanket statement here to all of you. Don't use a photo of me to help you get laid.
OKCupid是2004年。总之，我只是说他有选择，而不是开车去纽约，和瑞安去奇怪的夜店。哦，我非常了解约会网站和应用程序，因为珍娜，我火了，因为我的侄子，他刚接触Tinder，他的朋友们说：“你需要有一个钩子，这样女孩们就不会向右或向左滑动。”我不知道Tinder，什么的，她们滑动什么的，对吧？
Thank you. He was horrified and super embarrassed. He took the photo down immediately, said that he was really embarrassed his friends, talked him into that hook. But guess what? There's a lovely button. Wrap up button to the story. Years later, he in fact met a gal,
所以我侄子找到了一张我在里面的家庭照片。他就像：“是的，那是我和我来自《办公室》的阿姨。”它火了，对吧？因为突然间我的脸出现在Tinder上。我不得不给我的侄子们打电话。我不止一个。我说：“嘿，伙计们，我只是要对你们所有人做一个概括性的声明。不要用我的照片来帮助你们约炮。”
using a fabulous photo just of himself, and they started dating, they got engaged, and they got married. Aw. So look at that Tinder button, the Tinder wrap-up. See, that could have been Michael Scott. Right, but you know what? Michael probably would have done what my nephew did on the first pass and put a photo of like him and a random celebrity he had met. Well, instead, Michael is now in line for a second nightclub, and they're going to run into some problems because they are not allowed to go inside this nightclub unless they have dates. So they're going to team up with a woman's basketball team. The Jersey State varsity basketball team looked it up, no such thing. We had a fan question from Cat F. Were the women in line for the nightclub actually basketball
谢谢。他很震惊，超级尴尬。他立即删除了照片，说他真的很尴尬，他的朋友们说服了他用那个钩子。但猜猜怎么着？有一个可爱的按钮。故事的总结按钮。多年后，他实际上遇到了一个女孩，
players? And if so, were they on a team together in real life? No. They were not. They were not a basketball team. They were all hired background performers. They were hired through central casting. Now, the woman that Dwight ends up kissing, she had a speaking role. Her name was Cassie Fleigel, and she auditioned for the role through Allison Jones, and she was a former basketball player. But I guess the casting notice said they were looking for people who were six foot one or taller. And she is only, I mean, I'm putting only in quotes, five foot 11, but she still got the role because her audition was so good. Well, she looked very tall to me, especially with her heels on. Yeah, but everyone looks very tall to me, so maybe I'm not a good judge.
用了一张他自己的精彩照片，他们开始约会，他们订婚了，他们结婚了。啊。所以看看那个Tinder按钮，Tinder总结。看，那本可以是迈克尔·斯科特。对，但你知道吗？迈克尔可能在第一轮会做我侄子做的事，放一张他和某个他遇到的随机名人的照片。嗯，相反，迈克尔现在在第二个夜店排队，他们会遇到一些问题，因为除非他们有约会对象，否则他们不被允许进入这个夜店。所以他们要和一支女子篮球队组队。泽西州校队篮球队，查过了，没这回事。我们收到了卡特·F的粉丝提问。在夜店排队的女性真的是篮球队员吗？如果是的话，她们在现实生活中是在同一个队吗？不。她们不是。她们不是篮球队。她们都是雇来的背景演员。她们是通过中央选角雇来的。现在，德怀特最终亲吻的那个女人，她有一个说话的角色。她的名字叫卡西·弗莱格尔，她通过艾莉森·琼斯试镜了这个角色，她是一名篮球运动员。但我猜选角通知说他们正在寻找身高6英尺1英寸或更高的人。而她只有——我是说，我把“只有”放在引号里——5英尺11英寸，但她还是得到了这个角色，因为她的试镜太棒了。嗯，她在我看来很高，特别是在她穿高跟鞋的时候。是的，但每个人在我看来都很高，所以也许我不是一个好的评判者。
Well, back in the parking lot, folks are getting restless. Toby finds a football, wants to know if Pam wants to toss the old ball. And she's like, oh, yeah, I know how to throw a football. He's like, of course you do, because he's completely enamored with her. I know, of course you do? What? Yeah. Of course you do. You're a cool girl. You know how to throw a football. You probably can change a tire. Guess what? She can. Well, Pam does throw the football right into Meredith's face. We got some mail about this from Rohit Ow, who wanted to know how did we do this scene. Did you really hit Kate in the face with a ball? And if so, how many times did you have to film it? Let me tell you, I rewatched this episode with my daughter, Isabel, and I had forgotten about that moment. When it happened, we were both like, and Isabel said, Mom, I think she really got hit in the face. It looks like she got hit in the face.
嗯，回到停车场，人们变得焦躁不安。托比发现了一个足球，想知道帕姆是否想扔那个旧球。她说：“哦，是的，我知道怎么扔足球。”他说：“当然你知道，”因为他完全被她迷住了。我知道，当然你知道？什么？是的。当然你知道。你是个酷女孩。你知道怎么扔足球。你可能还会换轮胎。猜猜怎么着？她会。嗯，帕姆确实把足球扔到了梅雷迪思的脸上。我们收到了关于这个的邮件，来自罗希特·奥，他想知道我们是怎么拍这个场景的。你真的用球打了凯特的脸吗？如果是的话，你不得不拍了多少次？让我告诉你，我和我的女儿伊莎贝尔重看了这一集，我忘记了那个时刻。当它发生时，我们两个都像是，伊莎贝尔说：“妈妈，我想她真的被球打到了脸上。看起来她真的被球打到了脸上。”
And I said, Isabel, no way. There is no way. They threw a football at Kate's face. So I texted Kate, and I said, Kate, Isabel thinks she really got hit in the face with that football. And she said, Isabel's not wrong. That's what she texted. back and I said, Kate, you have to send in an audio clip about this moment. And she did. Here it is. Hey, it's Kate Flannery. There's a scene where Pam throws the football to Andy in the parking
我说：“伊莎贝尔，不可能。不可能。他们扔了一个足球在凯特的脸上。”所以我给凯特发了短信，我说：“凯特，伊莎贝尔认为她真的被那个足球打到了脸上。”她说：“伊莎贝尔没说错。”那是她回的短信。我说：“凯特，你必须发送一个关于这个时刻的音频片段。”她做了。这是它。嘿，我是凯特·弗兰纳里。有一个场景是帕姆在停车场把足球扔给安迪，
lot, but Meredith's face gets in the way. And for some reason, I was insistent on doing my own stunt. There was a stunt double there, but she did not work that night. For some reason, I thought it was funnier. It's always funnier to me when an actor can do their own stunt, but I didn't realize where the camera was, and my back was sorted to the camera, so it kind of could have been anybody. Yeah. But I will say they deflated the ball a little bit, which was supposed to help, but I don't know. I remember Ken Whittingham was directing, and I just remember, I think we did eight takes and we weren't done. We weren't done. And I just kind of felt like after the eight, when we hit number eight, I was like, this was a really stupid idea. And I slept really
但梅雷迪思的脸挡住了。出于某种原因，我坚持要自己做特技。那里有一个特技替身，但她那天晚上没工作。出于某种原因，我觉得这更搞笑。对我来说，演员能自己做特技总是更搞笑，但我没意识到摄像机在哪里，我的背对着摄像机，所以那可能是任何人。是的。但我会说他们把球放掉了一点气，这本应该有帮助，但我不知道。我记得肯·惠廷汉姆在导演，我只记得，我想我们拍了八次，我们还没拍完。我们还没拍完。我只是觉得在第八次之后，当我们拍到第八次时，我想：“这是一个非常愚蠢的主意。”那天晚上我睡得
well that night. I don't think I had a concussion or anything, but I had the weirdest dreams. It was kind of exhausting. And yeah, don't try this at home, kids. Okay, Ange, I want to lead with it's not the same as being the person who's getting hit in face with the ball, but it is not fun to be the person who has to throw a ball at their friend's face eight times. Eight balls to the face. That sounds wrong, but you know what I mean. That's eight balls.
很好。我不认为我脑震荡什么的，但我做了最奇怪的梦。这有点累人。是的，别在家里尝试这个，孩子们。好吧，安吉，我想先说，这和成为那个被球打到脸上的人不一样，但成为那个不得不八次把球扔向朋友脸的人并不好玩。八个球打到脸上。这听起来不对，但你知道我的意思。那是八个球。
Well, I would throw it and I was trying to make it not that hard hitting her face. And, you know, that was probably one of the reasons why we had to do so many takes because eventually Ken got me aside and said, Jenna, you need to throw the ball in her face because it's hitting her lightly, and we just need one where you hit her in the face with the ball. And I was like, oh my gosh, well, you have to believe that Pam knows how to throw a football. You have to sell it, so you would have chunked it. But man, Kate's saying, you know what, I want you to hit me in the face. Thank you for providing a stunt double, but I'll take this one for the team.
嗯，我会扔它，我试图让它不要那么用力地打她的脸。而且，你知道，那可能是我们不得不拍那么多遍的原因之一，因为最终肯把我拉到一边说：“珍娜，你需要把球扔到她的脸上，因为它打她太轻了，我们只需要一个你用球打到她脸上的镜头。”我当时想：“哦，天哪，好吧，你必须相信帕姆知道怎么扔足球。你必须卖力表演，所以你会用力扔。”但伙计，凯特说：“你知道吗，我想要你打我的脸。谢谢你提供特技替身，但我会为团队承担这个。”
Yeah. Way to go, Jenna. She had weird dreams. Way to go. I know. I'm sorry. Well, back in de club number two, Michael thinks he's met the love of his life. In fact, he wants to introduce her to his mom. He's so happy. And the camera operator kind of gives a little nod. She's over chatting someone else up. Yeah. And I was like, oh my gosh, here's the camera getting involved. I feel like the documentary crew normally does this with the movie. Pam and not so much with Michael. Yeah, it was nice that they sort of helped Michael not go too far down that imaginary relationship wrote. We've already done that with the chair model. So let's just Michael, we'll dose a reality. Take it easy. Yeah.
是的。干得好，珍娜。她做了奇怪的梦。干得好。我知道。对不起。嗯，回到夜店二号，迈克尔认为他遇到了他生命中的挚爱。事实上，他想把她介绍给他的妈妈。他太开心了。摄像师给了个小点头。她正在和别人聊天。是的。我当时想：“哦，天哪，摄像机参与进来了。”我觉得纪录片组通常在电影里这样做。帕姆，而不是迈克尔。是的，他们以某种方式帮助迈克尔不要在那个想象中的关系道路上走得太远，这很好。我们已经用椅子模特做过那个了。所以让我们只是迈克尔，我们会剂量现实。放轻松。是的。
Well, Ryan, meanwhile, is talking about an impending nuclear holocaust and jungle warfare. Mm-hmm. And then he takes the dance floor and starts dancing like a crazy problem. person and like shoves a girl and she shoves him back and now it's looking like it's going to be a brawl. Michael's talking to his mom as you do in the club. Right. And he's like, mom, I got to go. My friend's getting beaten up by some girls.
嗯，瑞安，与此同时，在谈论即将到来的核大屠杀和丛林战争。嗯哼。然后他走上舞池，开始像个疯狂的人一样跳舞，推了一个女孩，她把他推了回来，现在看起来要打架了。迈克尔正在和他的妈妈说话，就像你在夜店里做的那样。对。他说：“妈妈，我得走了。我的朋友被一些女孩打了。”
Well, have you know, Angela, we did employ a stunt person to do those fight scenes with Ryan. So all good there. Mm-hmm. All of these shenanigans lead to the group getting escorted out of the club. Troy makes a run for it, says, hey, don't take him to a hospital, and literally runs away. Yes. Well, we had to ask Noel what it was like to just shoot all of these club scenes. This was really an epic shoot. And here's what he had to say. Shooting the nightclub scenes were fun to do. I don't really remember any kind of improvising
嗯，你知道吗，安吉拉，我们确实雇了一个特技演员来拍那些和瑞安打架的场景。所以那里一切都好。嗯哼。所有这些恶作剧导致这群人被护送出夜店。特洛伊跑了，说：“嘿，别把他带到医院，”然后真的跑开了。是的。嗯，我们不得不问诺埃尔拍摄所有这些夜店场景是什么感觉。这确实是一次史诗般的拍摄。这是他不得不说的。拍摄夜店场景很有趣。我不记得在夜出那一集的那些场景中有什么即兴创作
during those few scenes in the night out episode. There was no really breaking character. I tried to stay professional. And the only kind of stuff that was funny during the scenes was the scenes with BJ and Steve, where he says, why won't the girls let me dance? And I would get a lot of recognition from my, don't take him to a hospital line where I'm like running down the dark alley. But another fun story was later, there was a day where we ended up, shooting quite late, and they had actually dismissed Steve Corral, and I was left last onset, shooting a monologue at past midnight, and that day I had at 7 a.m. call. I was dead tired
。没有真正打破角色。我试着保持专业。在场景中唯一有趣的事情是和BJ和史蒂夫的场景，他说：“为什么女孩们不让我跳舞？”我因为我的“别把他带到医院”的台词得到了很多认可，当时我正跑在黑暗的小巷里。但另一个有趣的故事是后来，有一天我们最终拍得很晚，他们实际上已经解散了史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我是最后一个在片场的人，在午夜过后拍摄独白，那天我早上7点有通告。我累死了
shooting this monologue over and over again, which we did eventually get, but leaving at 1 a.m. or so was quite interesting that day. Well, I really relate to what Noel said here, because many times I had talking heads at the end of the day and you're so tired and half of the cast has gone home and you're trying to focus. But yes, if you go to the deleted scenes, there's a talking head by Troy where he totally denies his role in helping Ryan get drugs. Well, we were also curious, Angela, to hear how often does Noel get recognized from being on the office? because he was in several episodes, and here's what he had to say. Oh, it's a big question. Do I get recognized?
一遍又一遍地拍摄这个独白，我们最终拍到了，但在凌晨1点左右离开那天很有趣。嗯，我真的很理解诺埃尔在这里所说的，因为很多时候我在一天结束时有访谈镜头，你太累了，一半的演员已经回家了，你正试图集中注意力。但是的，如果你去删减场景，有一个特洛伊的访谈镜头，他完全否认了他在帮助瑞安获得毒品中的角色。嗯，我们也很好奇，安吉拉，听到诺埃尔因为在《办公室》里而经常被认出来吗？因为他在几集里，这是他不得不说的。哦，这是一个大问题。我被认出来了吗？
But I do get recognized here and there at Starbucks or even during outings with my family when I'm just going to a dinner at a restaurant. A busboy will even say, weren't you on the office? It's just kind of a crack up to me. But I think the furthest recognition I got was a vacation trip to Hawaii. and a young lady in a store was actually chatting with my mom and asked if her son was on the office and she was all excited and actually asked me to come back and get a picture with her, which is a blast to do. It's just kind of funny to me. But I'm always open to signing autographs or taking pictures with fans. I actually quite enjoy it. And I just loved everything about the office. It was so much fun to do. But I always loved.
但我确实在这里和那里被认出来，在星巴克，甚至在和家人外出时，当我只是去餐馆吃晚饭时。一个服务生甚至会说：“你不是在《办公室》里吗？”这对我来说只是有点好笑。但我认为我得到的认出最远的是去夏威夷的度假旅行。商店里的一位年轻女士实际上正在和我妈妈聊天，问她的儿子是否在《办公室》里，她很兴奋，实际上让我回来和她合影，这很有趣。这对我来说只是有点好笑。但我总是乐于给粉丝签名或拍照。我实际上很享受它。我喜欢关于《办公室》的一切。这太有趣了。但我总是喜欢。
Being around everybody. So sweet. So sweet. Back in the lobby, Hank is still not there. He hasn't even left his house yet. I would dare to say Hank is in no hurry. Yeah. To go get them.
和大家在一起。太甜了。太甜了。回到大厅，汉克还没到。他甚至还没离开家。我敢说汉克一点也不着急。是的。去接他们。
No. Meanwhile in the lobby, Toby is cracking the jokes. Feeling pretty good about himself. Yeah. Pam is laughing at Toby's jokes. And he is so pleased with himself that without knowing it, he puts his hand on Pam's knee. and then like kind of strokes it with one finger,
不。与此同时在大厅里，托比在讲笑话。对自己感觉很好。是的。帕姆在笑托比的笑话。他对自己非常满意，以至于在不知不觉中，他把手放在了帕姆的膝盖上。然后像用一根手指抚摸它，
like his index finger. He kind of does a little swipy, swipy back and forth. And everyone clocks it. It is so cringy and awkward. So then Toby announces very suddenly that he's moving to Costa Rica, he runs out the door, hops the fence, and jogs home. Hops the fence.
就像他的食指。他做了一个小小的来回滑动。每个人都注意到了。这太令人尴尬和笨拙了。所以托比突然宣布他要搬到哥斯达黎加，他跑出门，跳过栅栏，慢跑回家。跳过栅栏。
This is no hop the fence type of fence. I rewatch this. This is a skis. scaling over a wall type of fence. It is really tall. When did Toby get so athletic? I also did screen grab. You can clearly see the stunt man.
这不是那种跳过栅栏的栅栏。我重看了这个。这是一个攀爬墙类型的栅栏。它真的很高。托比什么时候变得这么有运动天赋了？我也做了截图。你可以清楚地看到特技演员。
All right. Well, we got some fan mail about that from Emily, Abby, Kristy and Ellie. Was that really Paul Lieberstein jumping over the fence? No. I reached out to Paul. And Paul told me that he was willing to do it. He offered to try.
好吧。嗯，我们收到了一些关于那个的粉丝邮件，来自艾米丽、艾比、克里斯蒂和艾莉。真的是保罗·利伯斯坦跳过栅栏吗？不。我联系了保罗。保罗告诉我他愿意做。他主动提出尝试。
But they explained that we would have to shoot the scene multiple times, which increased the possible. for injury, and so they insisted on hiring a stunt person. He also said, quote, obviously, I'm a guy who does his own stunts, but I had to put the show first. Well, Paul, I get it. You wanted to do it. They said no. So you had to do what they said. I want to say something, Angela. I remember that we shot this scene very, very late on a Friday night. It was like 2 a.m. And I think that that. also increases the risk of injury.
但他们解释说，我们必须多次拍摄这个场景，这增加了受伤的可能性，所以他们坚持要聘请替身演员。他还说，引用一下，显然，我是一个自己做特技的人，但我必须把节目放在第一位。好吧，保罗，我明白了。你想自己做。他们说不行。所以你必须听他们的。我想说点什么，安吉拉。我记得我们是在周五深夜拍摄这个场景的。大约是凌晨2点。我认为这也增加了受伤的风险。
I think you should not attempt to do your own stunts at 2 a.m. So I think it was a wise move. Especially one that involves basically scaling something that's one story high. I mean, I'm exaggerating. But it's a really tall fence. It really is. He could have easily twisted an ankle or broken an arm. We had a fan theory by Carolyn G.
我认为你不应该尝试在凌晨2点做自己的特技。所以我认为这是一个明智的举动。尤其是涉及基本上攀爬一层楼高的东西。我是说，我夸张了。但那确实是一道很高的栅栏。确实如此。他很容易扭伤脚踝或摔断胳膊。我们有一个来自Carolyn G.的粉丝理论。
Since Toby jumps the fence with such apparent ease, It shows that he's someone who might be able to escape the police. Is this added evidence that Toby is the Scrant Strangler? I asked Paul about this. His response was, sounds smart. Mm-hmm. Dun-dun-dun. Perhaps if you were the Scranton Strangler,
由于托比跳过栅栏显得如此轻松，这表明他可能是一个能够逃脱警察追捕的人。这是托比是斯克兰顿勒杀手的额外证据吗？我问过保罗这个问题。他的回答是，听起来很聪明。嗯哼。当当当。也许如果你是斯克兰顿勒杀手，
you might have to set up residence outside of the country. Wow, that's a good point. Just saying. Well, hold up. What's happening? The cleaning crew has arrived. Yes. And the cleaning crew lets them out.
你可能不得不搬到国外居住。哇，那是个好观点。只是说说而已。等等。发生了什么？清洁人员到了。是的。清洁人员把他们放了出来。
Everyone is thrilled. Still no Hank. Oh, well, we'll get to that. Mm-hmm. Meanwhile, back in New York, the guys arrived at Ryan's apartment and Dwight and Michael. They're going to crash there for the night. They're kind of fighting over the sofa. Well, I want to say something about this apartment.
每个人都很激动。还是没有汉克。哦，好吧，我们会谈到那个。嗯哼。与此同时，回到纽约，伙计们到达了瑞安的公寓，德怀特和迈克尔。他们打算在那里过夜。他们有点在争抢沙发。好吧，关于这个公寓我想说点什么。
It looks like a one-bedroom studio. And I really appreciated that because I always thought the apartments on the show friends were ridiculous. I lived in New York. No one can afford those things. No. So I appreciated that Ryan had a very modest apartment in New York. I mean, it was very messy, but I'd like to point out at 18 minutes 59 seconds, he's got an enormous flat screen TV. Yeah. I wish we could have had a moment where Michael clocks that. Me too. And like maybe it was on an arm and he pulled it out and it actually went further than two inches. That would have been amazing. Well, Dwight, is going to sing Ryan a lullaby. And we had a fan question about it, Angela, from Cameron D.
它看起来像个一居室的工作室。我真的很欣赏这一点，因为我一直认为《老友记》里的公寓太荒谬了。我住在纽约。没人买得起那些房子。不。所以我很欣赏瑞安在纽约有一个非常简朴的公寓。我是说，它非常乱，但我得指出在18分59秒时，他有一个巨大的平板电视。是的。我希望我们能有一个迈克尔注意到这一点的时刻。我也是。就像也许它是在一个支架上，他把它拉出来，实际上它伸出了超过两英寸。那会很棒。好吧，德怀特要给瑞安唱摇篮曲。我们有一个关于它的粉丝问题，安吉拉，来自Cameron D.
and Joe S. Did the writers make up the lullaby that Dwight sings to Ryan? Or is it real? I think Rain improvised that moment. That's my guess. It's so much better than that. What? This is a real lullaby? And our script supervisor, Veda, taught it to rain. Amazing. Yes, it was one that her Austrian grandmother used to sing to her. But here is something that Mindy revealed in an interview. She said they never found out what the words meant. Veda just wrote it out phonetically for Rain right before the scene.
和Joe S.。编剧们编造了德怀特唱给瑞安听的摇篮曲吗？还是它是真实的？我认为雷恩即兴发挥了那一刻。这是我的猜测。它比那好多了。什么？这是一首真正的摇篮曲？我们的剧本主管Veda把它教给了雷恩。太棒了。是的，这是她奥地利祖母过去常唱给她听的。但这里有一件事是明迪在采访中透露的。她说他们从来不知道这些词是什么意思。Veda只是在场景拍摄前为雷恩用拼音写了下来。
So he could be singing like some creepy stuff. We don't know. Okay. As Ryan is going to sleep, he tells them he thinks his friend Troy might have a drug problem. And I think we all know who he's talking about. Michael gives him horrible advice, and then looks to Cameron says, best night ever. Yeah, Michael has a talking head where he said, you know, this whole time in his life, it's not the horniness, it's the loneliness.
所以他可能在唱一些令人毛骨悚然的东西。我们不知道。好吧。当瑞安准备睡觉时，他告诉他们他认为他的朋友特洛伊可能有毒品问题。我想我们都知道他在说谁。迈克尔给了他糟糕的建议，然后看着卡梅伦说，有史以来最好的夜晚。是的，迈克尔有一个访谈片段，他说，你知道，他生命中的这段时间，不是因为发情，而是因为孤独。
But how could he be lonely when he's with his voice? Like a famous person once said, boys on the side. Let's hear it for the boys. Well, I would not want to be Jim Helford on Monday because Hank shows up, sees that none of them are there and goes, son of a bitch. You know, I did have to wonder, Angela, did Hank not notice all of their cars in the parking lot when he chained it for the night? Or was he just like, listen, these guys didn't give me a bonus.
但他和他的声音在一起时怎么会孤独呢？就像一位名人曾经说过的，男孩在身边。让我们为男孩们欢呼吧。好吧，我可不想在周一做吉姆·赫尔福德，因为汉克出现了，看到他们都不在那里，就说，狗娘养的。你知道，我确实不得不怀疑，安吉拉，汉克在晚上锁门时没有注意到停车场里所有的车吗？还是他只是想，听着，这些家伙没给我奖金。
I don't know. I'm leaving. There's probably a bit of that. They didn't call me. They didn't give me a bonus. I'm out of here. I'm out of here. Good luck, A-holes.
我不知道。我要走了。可能有一点那种成分。他们没给我打电话。他们没给我奖金。我离开这里了。我离开这里了。祝你们好运，混蛋们。
Well, that was night out, you guys. Thank you so much for sending in your question. Questions in your comments? Yeah, thank you to Kate Flannery and to Noel P.tok for sending in your audio clips. And to Terry Carnation. Terry, you were supposed to leave our Zoom. I've been here the whole time. Cassie, Cassie.
好吧，伙计们，这就是《夜出》。非常感谢你们发来问题。问题在你们的评论里？是的，感谢凯特·弗兰纳里和诺埃尔·P.托克发来音频片段。还有特里·卡内申。特里，你应该离开我们的Zoom会议的。我一直都在这里。卡西，卡西。
It's been a delightful conversation. I'm definitely going to watch this episode of television. It looks fantastic. But my theory holds up. The building is definitely possessed. All right. Well, okay, Cassie. Thank you for listening to the Office Women podcast.
这是一次愉快的谈话。我一定会看这一集电视节目。它看起来棒极了。但我的理论站得住脚。这栋楼绝对是被附身了。好吧。好吧，卡西。感谢收听《办公室女士》播客。
This is Terry Carnation, host of Dark Air with Terry Carnation. You've been wonderful. We'll see you next week, guys. Cassie, hit the button. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
我是特里·卡内申，《特里·卡内申的黑暗空气》主持人。你们太棒了。下周见，伙计们。卡西，按那个按钮。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯酒。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。